zum sondergipfel des europäischen rates
ende mai und da geht es natürlich um die
folgen des ukraine krieges um
energieeinsparung aber auch um die
verteidigungsfähigkeit und deswegen habe
ich mir zwei kundige abgeordnete
eingeladen einmal begrüßt ganz herzlich
michael roth den vorsitzenden des
auswärtigen ausschusses und jürgen hardt
den außenpolitischen sprecher der
cdu/csu herr roth die wir müssen ganz
aktuell darauf gucken verteidigung habe
ich gerade angesprochen da geht es jetzt
um den nato-beitritt wunsch von schweden
und finnland gestern war der
außenminister der türkei in amerika man
hat verhandelt sich offensichtlich noch
nicht geeinigt wir sehen auch hier
wieder wie schwierig das ist wenn das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip gilt was machen
die türken da denn nichts wäre ja
wichtiger gegenüber dem russischen
despoten als dass man gemeinsam auftritt
und er verhindert jetzt zunächst in
weitere warum
politik in zeiten des krieges darf nicht
zu einem basar vorkommen und ich hoffe
dass am ende von der nato ein
geschlossenes signal ausgeht solidarität
und rationalität denn es liegt im
interesse aller nato staaten dass zwei
stabile demokratien mit starken armee zu
uns stoßen nicht nur weil sie selbst
angst vor der schreckensherrschaft
putins haben sondern weil sie auch jetzt
bereit sind intim nato mitzuarbeiten wir
in deutschland können vermutlich kaum
nachempfinden was das für eine
schwerwiegende auch dramatische
entscheidung für finnland und für
schweden war finden hat eine fast 1400
kilometer grenze zu russland es gab dort
eine lange
zurückhaltung einer einem militärbündnis
beizutreten und jetzt hat putin abermals
verloren denn
jetzt tritt die nato an die direkte
grenze zu russland und das ist eine
weitere krachende niederlage für ihn er
hat aber die frage auch an sie noch mal
warum machen dass die türken ich vermute
dass da ganz handfeste türkische
interessen dahinter stehen ich glaube
aber dass die auch aus rumba sind ich
bin mir sicher dass der nato-gipfel im
sommer beschließen wird die finden und
die schäden in die nato aufzunehmen ich
plädiere dafür dass dann der deutsche
bundestag deshalb wird es glaube ich
eigentlich dann auch möglichst das
ratifikation gesetz macht also die
deutsche zustimmung zu dieser
entscheidung abgibt so dass die finden
und die schweden auch rasch unter den
schutzschirm des artikel 5 der nato
kommt und für uns als europäische union
als mitglieder der eu ist es ja sowieso
eine entlastung und zusätzliche stärkung
denn wir haben ja auch im eu-vertrag
eine beistandsverpflichtung gegenüber
unseren eu-mitgliedern finnland und
schweden nach dem vertrag selbst und
wenn das durch die nato schutzschirm in
anführungsstrichen ergänzt wird ist das
eine stärkung deswegen ist das innerhalb
der europäischen union eigentlich völlig
unumstritten dass das passiert der
bundeskanzler hat in seiner
regierungserklärung am 27 februar hier
eine wegweisende rede gehalten im
deutschen haus heute im deutschen
bundestag heute erneute
regierungserklärung und die zentrale
ankündigung von damals nämlich das 100
milliarden sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr das steckt fest warum
das ist ein ganz weitreichender
beschluss der ja nicht nur auswirkungen
hat auf deutschland selbst sondern auch
auf unsere bündnispartner wir setzen
damit ein signal wir werden unserer
verantwortung für landesverteidigung
aber auch für die verteidigung unseres
bündnisses gerecht und wir ermutigen und
darm und damit natürlich auch andere
diesem beispiel zu folgen aber es geht
um 100 milliarden euro wir brauchen
dabei auch die zustimmung von cdu csu
das halte ich auch für wichtig nicht nur
weil wir zwei drittel mehrheit für eine
grundgesetzänderung brauchen sondern
weil auch gegenüber unserer eigenen
bevölkerung deutlich gemacht werden
sollte dass es hier nicht um aufrüstung
und militarisierung geht sondern dass
wir die bundeswehr endlich in einer lage
versetzen die sie braucht um in einer
zeit des krieges wehrhaft zu sein und da
haben wir noch ein paar gespräche zu
führen aber ich finde wichtig dass wir
uns einigen ob das nun eine woche später
oder eine woche früher ist das ist für
mich erst mal zweitrangig aber ich habe
die union und natürlich auch die
koalition so verstanden dass wir alle
hinter diesen großen historischen
projekt stehen er hat erst wurde mit der
union gar nicht gesprochen hat friedrich
merz gesagt es gab jetzt fruchtbare
gespräche die union ist schon lange von
der forderung wird das zwei prozent ziel
ins grundgesetz zu schreiben soll
begleitgesetz geben da blockieren so ein
bisschen die sozialdemokraten bei den
100 milliarden rein für die bundeswehr
blockieren er die grünen wie ist der
sachstand im moment wir als cdu csu
opposition plädieren dafür dass das was
der kanzler am 27 februar gesagt hat
wort für wort umgesetzt wird er hat
gesagt 100 milliarden für verteidigung
im rahmen eines sondervermögens um zwei
prozent für die bundeswehr gemessen am
bruttoinlandsprodukt ab jetzt und wir
sagen das sind zwei seiten ein und
derselben medaille wenn wir 100
milliarden die bundeswehr investiert
aber nicht gleichzeitig dafür sorgen
dass sie dieses gerät auch einführen
betreiben warten nutzen kann weil das
geld fehlt für personal oder für
material für ersatzteile dann würde das
ins leere laufen deswegen sind legen wir
großen wert darauf dass diese beiden
teile dieser aussage wenn ich die 100
milliarden aber eben auch die 2 prozent
klar verbindlich im deutschen bundestag
beschlossen werden und das ist auch ein
punkt an dem wir im augenblick noch
regen aber ich glaube man kann es nicht
voneinander trennen man muss es im
zusammenhang sind denn sonst würde das
gerät angeschafft werden und es würde
dann möglicherweise nicht dauerhaft in
der bundeswehr sinnvoll genutzt werden
können also fingerhakeln wie ich die
abgeordneten kenne wird es irgendwann
eine lösung geben wohl nicht mehr im mai
herr roth gucken wir weiter der
bundestag hat ja auch beschlossen
schwere waffen zu liefern an die ukraine
dann hat der bundeskanzler kurz danach
gesagt also mit den sieben
panzerhaubitzen und mit denen gepard
panzern die ja beide sind ja noch lange
nicht drüber in der ukraine angekommen
da reicht es jetzt erst mal mehr können
wir nicht liefern jetzt ist heute zu
lesen dass im rahmen des umtauschs
leopard-2-panzer 15 stück an die türkei
geliefert wird die dann wiederum waffen
in die ukraine liefern wie ist der
sachstand werden wir noch weiteres
schweres gerät liefern oder nur im
rahmen dieses ringtausch also erstmal
bin ich sehr froh dass wir im bundestag
eine breite mehrheit gefunden haben um
unsere solidarität gegenüber der ukraine
zu bekunden humanitär politisch
finanziell aber eben auch militärisch
die ukraine braucht das was die
verteidigungsfähigkeit und da stehen
vermutlich noch lange schwere wochen und
monate vor ihr und dabei braucht sie
auch die unterstützung deutschlands
ich bin froh dass es jetzt endlich
vorangeht der ringtausch ist ja eine
sehr pragmatische und kurzfristige
lösung um die ukraine auch schnell in
die lage versetzt zu versetzen das gerät
zu bekommen was sie dringend braucht und
ich bin tschechien sehr dankbar dass wir
jetzt diesen ringtausch ermöglichen
können moderne technologie aus
deutschland und technologie aus
sowjetischer produktion direkt in die
ukraine beim gepaart ist es ein bisschen
schwieriger das ist ein industrieprojekt
wir müssen jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass
die ausbildung der ukrainischen
soldatinnen und soldaten rasch
gewährleistet wird und es wir brauchen
eine höhere stückzahl an munition und da
befindet sich die bundesregierung
momentan in einem intensiven gesprächen
mit anderen partnern die über diese
munition noch verfügen mit das dilemma
mit der schweiz die ja nicht liefern
will kennen wir inzwischen das ist
traurig aber vielleicht gibt es auch
daten noch eine umkehr weil wenn man die
ukraine in diesen tagen nicht
unterstützt dann leistet man
unterstützung für russland und das
wollen sicherlich auch unsere schweizer
freundinnen und freunde nicht wobei es
gibt ja von dieser rüstungsfirma die
munition herstellt nicht nur ein werk in
der schweiz sondern in italien und
verteidigungsexperten sagen bevor der
gepard ausgebildet ist und repariert das
haben längst genug munition also noch
einmal ich finde es wichtig dass wir mit
dem gepard ein attraktives angebot
leisten damit die wehrhaftigkeit der
ukraine gesteigert werden kann und
wichtig ist genügend munition und die
ausbildung muss gewährleistet werden und
da müssen wir jetzt alle unserer
verantwortung gerecht werden der
bundestagsbeschluss setzt dafür die
voraussetzungen das ist glaube ich auch
wichtig gegenüber unserer eigenen
bevölkerung die sich sorgen macht aber
diese breite politische mehrheit in
deutschland
gewährleistet dass wir keine
unabsehbaren risiken eingehen aber wir
müssen uns auch an die seite der ukraine
stellen auch militärisch und wir müssen
ein klares stopp schild gegenüber dem
russischen aggressor aufstellen er hat
die verteilungs ministerin der
bundeskanzler sagen also mehr schweres
gerät können wir auch gar nicht liefern
ich glaube der kanzleramtsminister
gerade auch noch mal in einem interview
der deutschen welle gesagt sonst ist die
bundeswehr gar nicht
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
kanzleramtsminister noch hinzu gesetz
eigentlich sind wir ohne das bündnis
wenig
verteidigungsfähigkeit nicht aber der
bundestag beschlossenen schwere waffen
zu liefern wir haben das gemeinsam
beschlossen die entscheidung gibt ist ja
in die diskussion über diesen antrag
nein geraten ich habe den eindruck dass
gebhard nicht ganz oben auf der
wunschliste der ukrainer stand weil es
eben ein relativ komplexes waffensystem
ist wo man lange ausbilden muss wir
hätten früher beginnen müssen mit der
ausbildung ukrainischen soldaten etwa an
den panzerhaubitzen wenn wir die
situation in der ukraine sehen dass
insbesondere verhindert werden muss dass
die russischen truppen städte besetzen
um dort entsprechende massaker
anzurichten das sind panzerhaubitzen
eine gute abwehr waffe und wenn sie wenn
wir vor acht wochen oder vor zehn wochen
mit der ausbildung begonnen hätten dann
wären die franzosen und die soldaten
jetzt schon in der ukraine diese
verzögerung haben wir beklagt die haben
auch jetzt den eindruck dass die anträge
von rüstungsunternehmen auf export etwa
von marder schützenpanzern nicht mit der
geschwindigkeit im kanzleramt bearbeitet
werden wie wir uns das wünschen das
werden wir weiter aktiv verfolgen als
oppositionsfraktion wir werden
vielleicht nicht immer dass auf der
großen bühne machen aber es muss mehr
speed eingelegt werden das was der
bundestag beschlossen hat muss die
regierung auch machen sonst braucht der
bundestag eine andere regierung aber rot
noch mal zu der frage wir können nicht
mehr waffen abgeben die dialektik
verstehe ich nicht ganz wir geben jetzt
leopard-2-panzer übrigens von der
industrie die werden auch repariert und
dann hingestellt für die tschechen und
was aber noch zu lesen ist ist dass wir
verhandeln dass die tschechen 50 solcher
panzer und abkaufen können ich habe ja
immer gedacht wir können keine waffen
abgeben also das versteht kein mensch
das kann man sehr gut verstehen wenn man
es gut genug erklärt und das versuche
ich jetzt einfach mal wir haben
einerseits die sehr begrenzten bestände
der bundeswehr selbst und da hat die
bundesregierung deutlich gemacht wir
können kaum noch etwas liefern aus
eigenen vorhandenen beständen weil wir
ansonsten auch unseren verpflichtungen
in der nato nicht mehr gerecht zu werden
vermögen das zweite sind natürlich
lieferungen die über die industrie
laufen wie beispielsweise jetzt auch bei
gepard die müssen dann teilweise noch
gewartet werden die ausbildung muss
gesichert werden aber selbstverständlich
kann man über den pool der industrie
noch weiteres zur verfügung stellen und
da rate ich sehr zu einer ganz
pragmatischen lösung die ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer wissen selbst am besten was
sie brauchen und dann müssen wir im team
nato im thema eu rasch klären welches
land welche industrie kann am
schnellsten und am besten und am
sichersten das liefern was die ukraine
braucht also es geht nur in einer engen
zusammenarbeit mit den staaten
tschechien habe angesprochen das scheint
zu funktionieren die bekommen dann von
uns ersatz war sie schneller liefern
können dann brauchen wir eine
zusammenarbeit mit der industrie und wir
brauchen natürlich auch eine enge
zusammenarbeit mit der ukraine denn die
muss schließlich sagen was sie braucht
residenz gehört gesagt er richtet sich
auf einen längeren krieg ein dann ist ja
die frage dieses ringtausch es auf dauer
für die bundesregierung vielleicht gar
nicht mehr machbar weil immer mehr
waffen gebraucht werden aber sei es drum
herr borel dass der außenbeauftragte der
eu hat jetzt gerade eine wunschliste
aufgestellt was die eu an waffensystemen
braucht er hat wenn man das ist ja auch
ein europäischer gipfel wenn man auf die
europäer guckt muss man nicht
konstatieren dass sie ohne die
amerikaner eigentlich gar nicht
handlungsfähig sind und wenn man eine
europäische gemeinsame haben je weiter
voranbringen will muss man da nicht
anfangen mit diesen vielen geld die 100
milliarden und anderes geld in anderen
eu-ländern
waffensysteme anzuschaffen aber nicht
jedes land die gleichen sondern daneben
diese liste von hamburger abarbeiten ich
glaube dass das ein großes problem ist
innerhalb der europäischen nato partner
dass wir zu viele gleichartige
waffensysteme parallel im einsatz haben
was enorm die kosten erhöht hat und auch
die ausbildung im übrigen schwierig
macht ich glaube dass wir bei den
neubeschaffungen der bundeswehr enger
mit anderen eu mindestens europäischen
nato partner kooperieren sollten und
auch bestimmte dinge gemeinsam machen
sollten zum beispiel die wartung zum
beispiel die ausbildung an den
waffensystemen das spart viel geld und
es gibt ja deutsch-französische
insbesondere deutsch-französische
bemühungen um gemeinsamer waffen sowohl
für das luftverteidigung als auch für
das land system also panzer zukunft
panzer zukunft das steckt leider
nach wie vor in schwierigkeiten und ich
glaube dass der weckruf aus kiew dass
wir jetzt gas geben müssen in der eu
hoffentlich auch dafür sorgt dass diese
konsolidierung gemeinsame
rüstungsanstrengungen voranschreitet ich
glaube auch dass wir als europäer immer
auch waffensysteme der nato haben
sollten die amerikanischen system
gleichwertigkeit ebenbürtig sind denn
wie wir von einer art waffe nur ein
system mit der nato einführen dann ist
natürlich der das herstellten einem
enormen vorteil der konkurrenz belebt
auch da das geschäft und die qualität
wird besser wenn wir europäische und
amerikanische top systeme zur verfügung
hat der amerikanische präsident hat
gesagt es ist durchaus möglich dass die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt das ist
eigentlich auch das ziel des westens der
bundeskanzler das so deutlich nicht
gesagt er hat ja auch schon mit dem
russischen präsidenten telefoniert hat
er nochmal darauf hingewiesen dass ein
schneller waffenstillstand kommen muss
das keine nazis in kiew sitzen und dass
die ukraine verantwortlich ist wie die
lebensmittel situation auf der welt aber
er hat zum beispiel auch nicht vom
rückzug der russischen truppen aus dem
ukraine gebiet gesprochen wird er das
heute hier tun wird er klar definieren
wie dieser krieg zu ende gehen kann und
dass die russen sich zurückziehen müssen
wir haben im team westen gemeinsam mit
der ukraine ein strategisches ziel dass
die ukraine als freies souveränes
demokratisches land diesen krieg
übersteht das ist unser ziel und am ende
muss die ukraine selbst entscheiden
welchen kompromiss sie bereit ist
einzugehen was mich an der debatte
wahnsinnig stört ist dass wir niemals an
in richtung kreml fragen was müsst ihr
denn eigentlich an leistungen erbringen
damit wir diesen krieg diplomatisch
friedlich beenden können und
selbstverständlich muss ein
waffenstillstand geknüpft sein an einen
rückzug der russischen truppen das hat
der bundeskanzler auch immer wieder
gesagt und ob er es heute nochmal sagt
weiß ich nicht aber es wäre sicherlich
nochmal ein klares signal um auch
missverständnissen vorzubeugen und er
hat jetzt wenn wir gar nicht über die
energieproblematik gesprochen aber das
wird vielleicht jetzt gleich in der
debatte der fall sein der bundeskanzler
wird zunächst eine regierungserklärung
abgeben dann werden die abgeordneten 90
minuten diskutieren sie können live
dabei sein ich geh beraten
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen guten morgen die sitzung ist
eröffnet
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung möchte
ich dem kollegen thomas rachel
nachträglich zu seinem sechzigsten
geburtstag im namen des ganzen hauses
gratulieren
[Applaus]
dann haben wir zunächst noch einige
wahlen durchzuführen auf vorschlag der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen soll die
kolleginnen
tesfai jesus ich hoffe ich habe das
richtig ausgesprochen
das war jesus
als stellvertretendes mitglied des
kuratoriums der stiftung haus der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt werden darüber
besteht
einvernehmen ich sehe jedenfalls keinen
widerspruch dann ist das so dann ist die
kollegen kolleginnen
tesfai jesus als stellvertretendes
mitglied des kuratoriums der stiftung
haus der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt in den deutschen
ethikrat soll auf vorschlag der fraktion
der spd herr professor dr mark schwerer
als nachfolger für herrn professor
doktor doktor hat so andreas kruse
gewählt werden auch hier sehe ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist das so der fall
damit ist herr professor dr mack schwede
als mitglied des ethikrates
gewählt in den stiftungsrat der stiftung
flucht vertreibung versöhnung sollen auf
vorschlag der beauftragten der
bundesregierung für kultur und medien
als vertreter des bundesministeriums des
inneren und für heimat herr jörn thießen
als nachfolger für herrn dr michael
frese als vertreterin des auswärtigen
amtes die abgeordnete katja keul als
nachfolgerin für den abgeordneten
michael roth und als vertreter für die
beauftragte der bundesregierung für
kultur und medien herr doktor andreas
gergen als nachfolger für die
abgeordnete monika grütters
als ordentliche mitglieder gewählt
werden weiterhin sollen auf vorschlag
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen die
abgeordnete
artist for jesus
als ordentliches mitglied und der
abgeordnete erhard grundl als
stellvertretendes mitglied sowie auf
vorschlag der fdp fraktion der
abgeordnete thomas hacker als
ordentliches und der abgeordnete ulrich
leichter als stellvertretendes mitglied
in den stiftungsrat gewählt werden auch
diesbezüglich sehe ich keinen
widerspruch
dann sind herr thiessen herr dr görgen
die kollegin keul und tipps für jesus
sowie der kollege hacker als ordentliche
mitglieder und die kollegen grunde und
lechte als stellvertretende mitglieder
des stiftungsrates der stiftung flucht
vertreibung und versöhnung
gewählt
wir kommen nun zur tagesordnung heute
folgt im anschluss an die gremien wahlen
eine aktuelle stunde auf verlangen der
fraktionen der cdu/csu mit dem titel für
einen klaren kurs in der finanzpolitik
widersprüche beenden inflation bekämpfen
gerecht entlasten
ich rufe auf den
ja ok vielen dank ich habe noch auf der
ehrentribüne einen gast zu begrüßen
ich begrüße auf der ehrentribüne den
präsidenten des parlaments der republik
nord mazedonien seine exzellenz herr
talat schaaf wäre
im namen aller kolleginnen und kollegen
des deutschen bundestags begrüße ich sie
herzlich und ich hoffe dass sie
aufenthalt und ihre weitere weiteres
parlamentarisches wirken
mit unseren guten wünschen weitergeht
ich rufe jetzt auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 8 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch den
bundeskanzler zum ausserordentlichen
europäischen rat am dreißigsten und 31
für die aussprache im anschluss an diese
regierungserklärung sind 90 minuten
vereinbart
und das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung hat nun der
bundeskanzler per olaf scholz
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
der frieden ist nun selbstverständlich
krieg ist unvorstellbar geworden
zehn jahre ist es her dass der damalige
präsident des europäischen rats herman
van rompuy diese sätze gesprochen hat in
oslo war das bei der verleihung des
friedensnobelpreises an die europäische
union
herman van rompoy worte waren damals
natürlich auf die lage im innern der
europäischen union gemünzt und in der
tat krieg zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union ist auch heute
unvorstellbar das ist und bleibt die
größte errungenschaft der europäischen
einigung
doch beim blick auf die ruinen von mario
pohl die hier oder charkiw beim gedanken
denken an die massen gedanken die
massengräber von butter oder posthum l
bei den bildern zerschossene häuser
zertrümmerte autos und lebloser körper
unschuldiger frauen männer und kinder
wird uns schmerzhaft bewusst
krieg ist eben nicht überall
unvorstellbar geworden auch in europa
nicht
und frieden ist nur dann
selbstverständlich
wenn wir bereit sind ihn zu verteidigen
das ist die lehre die wir aus russlands
brutalen angriff auf die ukraine ziehen
darin liegt die zeitenwende von der ich
ende februar hier in diesem haus
gesprochen habe liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unterschiedliche
herausforderungen und krisen hat die
europäische union in den letzten jahren
bewältigt der krieg in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft ist ohne
jeden zweifel die größte
in einem aber er findet auch diese krise
den vorangegangenen einmal mehr erleben
wir je größer der druck von außen ist
desto entschlossener und geeinter
handelt die europäische union
weil der von putin entfachte krieg allem
widerspricht wofür diese union steht die
europäische union ist ein
friedensprojekt geboren aus der idee den
krieg und die feindschaft zwischen den
völkern europas ein für alle mal zu
überwinden
und so länder sind offen frei und
demokratisch
anders als putins autokratie
und wir begegnen uns mit respekt und in
dem wissen dass ausgleich und
kompromissbereitschaft keine schwächen
sind sondern es darin unsere stärke
liegt
mit dieser haltung werden wir die
europäische union fortentwickeln und
dabei ihre geschlossenheit war
auch immer 0 makro hat das war sein
besuch letzte woche bekräftigt ich bin
dem französischen präsidenten daher sehr
dankbar dass ihn seine erste reise nach
der wiederwahl hierher nach berlin
geführt hat darin liegt auch ein
bekenntnis zur deutsch französischen
zusammenarbeit die stets mehr war als
ein bilaterales
projektierer auftrag er wirklich darin
lösung für die zukunft zu finden die für
alle
mitgliedstaaten tragen
das muss immer der antrieb sein des
deutsch-französischen motor die
zeitenwende erfordert dass wir auch in
europa über den tag hinaus denken dabei
werden wir anknüpfen an die vielen guten
vorschläge die die europäischen
bürgerinnen und bürger im rahmen der
zukunftskonferenz entwickelt haben am
europatag heute vor zehn tagen haben sie
die ergebnisse vorgestellt
den bürgerinnen und bürgern geht es um
eine bürgernahe und effizientere union
das wird auch unser fokus
viele der vorschläge sind ganz konkret
die bürgerinnen und bürger wünschen sich
zum beispiel mehr konsequenz beim
klimaschutz fortschritte bei der
europäischen verteidigung ein
gerechteres und inklusives europa mit
mehr sozialen miteinander
vieles davon kann schnell umgesetzt
werden dafür braucht es keine
langjährigen änderung der verträge dazu
reichen gute vorschläge der kommission
das gilt auch für viele ideen um die eu
effizienter zu machen wie die von uns
geforderten mehrheitsentscheidungen im
gerade hier sehe ich dass sich in den
letzten wochen und monaten immer mehr
dieser idee anschließen gut so
wenn die sache es erfordert dann können
wir über eine änderung der verträge
reden auch über ein konvent dass es kein
tabu
wichtig aber ist dass wir dabei
größtmöglichen konsens erzielen denn
wenn wir eines nicht brauchen in dieser
zeit dann ist das eine kontroverse zeit
und energie rauben der nabelschau zu
institutionellen fragen
das ginge auch an den erwartungen vorbei
die die bürgerinnen und bürger an ein
funktionierendes europa haben die
zeitenwende betrifft auch europa deshalb
ja wir werden die eu weiter entwickeln
und genauso mutig und entschlossen wie
unsere nationale antwort wird auch unser
europäische antwort darauf ausfallen
mit diesem ziel werde ich in zehn tagen
zum sondertreffen der staats und
regierungschefs nach brüssel reisen
deutschlands rolle dabei ist für mich
ganz klar als größtes land tragen wir
besondere verantwortung für die
einigkeit der europäischen union und
mehr noch selten zuvor war unsere
zusammenarbeit mit den
wirtschaftsstarken demokratien den g7 so
effektiv und so intensiv wie in diesen
tagen und wochen unter unserem vorsitz
deshalb blicke ich auch voll zuversicht
auf unser gipfeltreffen ende juni in
emma
und selten zuvor war das
transatlantische bündnis so eng so
lebendig und so essentiell wie heute
präsident biden hat großen anteil daran
und dafür bin ich sehr dankbar
uns alle ein einziehen russland darf
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen die ukraine
muss bestehen
darum geht es darum geht es bei allem
was wir tun bei unseren sanktionen gegen
russland bei der aufnahme millionen
geflüchteter in der europäischen union
bei der humanitären
entwicklungspolitischen und
wirtschaftlichen unterstützung der
ukraine
und ja auch bei der lieferung von waffen
einschließlich schwerem gerät
ich weiß das ist nicht unumstritten in
unserem land auch sie erleben in ihren
wahlkreisen sich viele kontroverse
diskussion sie bekommen zuschriften von
bürgern und bürgern die sich sorgen
machen mir geht es nicht anders
manchen geht unsere unterstützung nicht
weit genug andere wiederum geht sie viel
zu weit und nahezu alle bürgerinnen und
bürger ein die sorge um den frieden in
der ukraine aber auch hier bei uns
ich will daher eines ganz deutlich sagen
einen brutal angegriffen land bei der
verteidigung zu helfen darin liegt keine
eskalation
sondern einen beitrag dazu den angriff
abzuwehren
und damit schnellstmöglich die gewalt zu
beenden
noch immer glaubt putin dass er einen
diktat frieden herbeibomben kann
doch er irrt sich
so wie er sich schon im blick auf die
entschlossenheit der ukraine ukraine und
die geschlossenheit unserer bündnisse
und allianzen geirrt hat
einen diktat frieden wird es nicht geben
weil die ukraine ukraine ihnen nicht
akzeptieren und wir auch nicht
erst wenn putin das begreift erst wenn
er versteht dass er die verteidigung der
ukraine nicht brechen kann dann wird er
bereit seien ernsthaft über frieden zu
verhandeln
deshalb stärken wir die ukraine den
rücken auch militärisch wir tun das
überlegt abgewogen und international eng
abgestimmt und es bleibt bei dem was ich
den bürgerinnen und bürgern am 8 mai
gesagt habe es wird keine deutschen
alleingänge geben alles was wir tun muss
russland mehr schaden und zu selbst und
unseren partnern die unternehmen nichts
was die nato zur kriegspartei werden
lässt und
wir werden unsere eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit sichern und
stärken
dafür auch die bundeswehr das
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
wir sind dazu in guten gesprächen auch
mit ihrer partei die bei herz und das
sondervermögen fest im grundgesetz zu
verankern dafür bin ich dankbar
denn so bringen wir gemeinsam zum
ausdruck regierung und opposition wir
stellen uns unserer staatspolitischen
verantwortung
das sondervermögen garantiert die
freiheit und sicherheit unseres landes
in dieser schwierigen zeit und mehr noch
mit dem sondervermögen senden wir eine
klare botschaft an freunde und
verbündete ja wir meinen es ernst wenn
wir von beistandspflicht und kollektiver
verteidigung reden
das bevölkerungsreichste und
wirtschaftsstärkste nation europas
leistet deutschland dazu seinen
angemessenen beitrag
das erwarten unsere freunde und
ernährten von uns im rahmen der nato
ziele und dazu sind wir bereit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen denn wir wissen
es ist diese bereitschaft dieses
bekenntnis einer für alle und alle für
einen das unser transatlantisches
bündnis trägt
welch großem wert diese gewissheit hat
was zeigt der wunsch schweden zum
finnlands sich der nato anzuschließen
und ich sage ohne jedes zögern liebe
freundinnen und freunde in schweden und
finnland ihr seid uns herzlich
willkommen mit euch an unserer seite
wird die sache
russlands angriff auf die ukraine hat
auch viele andere länder europas dazu
gebracht neu über ihre sicherheit ans
nachzudenken viele investieren seither
deutlich mehr in ihre verteidigung oft
standen dabei unsere entscheidung
partner umso wichtiger ist es dass wir
diese nun mit dem sondervermögen
umsätzen
auf eines werden wir dabei achten unsere
verteidigungssystem und unsere
investitionen müssen auch europäische
enger koordiniert und besser aufeinander
abgestimmt werden wir alle wissen
wir alle wissen seit jahren und die
teure und ineffiziente vielzahl
unterschiedlichster waffensystem europa
so kann es nicht weitergehen
deshalb wollen wir unsere
technologischen möglichkeiten stärker
gemeinsam nutzen und die europäische
verteidigungsindustrie enger verzahnt
über die notwendigen schritte werden wir
beim sondergipfel ende des monats
beraten es geht um mehr effizienz und
mehr komplementarität
und nicht zuletzt geht es angesichts der
russischen bedrohung auch darum jetzt
einen großen schritt richtung zukunft zu
gehen zu einer gemeinsamen europäischen
verteidigung die eine starke säule
innerhalb der nato bleibt
den blick voraus zu werfen
heißt auch sich in sachen ukraine weiter
zu unterhalten
hoffentlich früher als später wird der
krieg enden und schon jetzt ist klar der
wiederaufbau der zerstörten
infrastruktur die wiederbelebung der
ukrainischen wirtschaft all das wird
milliarden kosten
daher müssen wir als europäische union
jetzt die vorarbeiten für einen
solidaritätsfonds beginn der sich aus
beiträgen der eu und unserer
internationalen partner speist
damit werden wir den ukrainern und
ukrainern helfen die zerstörung zu
beseitigen die der krieg hinterlässt
solidarisch als europäische freunde und
nachbarn
bereits beim treffen der staats- und
regierungschefs in verse haben wir klar
gesagt die ukraine ist teil unserer
europäischen familien das gilt mit dem
solidaritätsfonds werden wir sie auf
ihrem europäischen weg unterstützen und
dabei rechtsstaatlichkeit gute
regierungsführung und die demokratie
stärken
die ukraine hat beantragt mitglied der
europäischen union zu werben die
kommission wird vor dem europäischen rat
voraussichtlich ende juni ihre
einschätzung zu dem antrag abgeben
und zugleich wissen wir alle
immer neue micro hat recht wenn er
darauf hinweist dass der
beitrittsprozess keine sache von ein
paar monaten oder einigen jahren ist und
deshalb wollen wir uns jetzt darauf
konzentrieren die ukraine schnell und
pragmatisch zu unterstützen über den
besten weg dafür werde ich mit meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen beraten
[Applaus]
auf dem weg in die eu keine abkürzung
gibt es doch ein gebot der fairness
gegenüber den sechs ländern des
westlichen balkan
seit jahren unternehmen sie intensive
reformen und bereiten sich auf den
beitritt vor
dass wir unsere zusagen ihnen gegenüber
einhalten ist nicht nur eine frage
unserer glaubwürdigkeit
heute mehr denn je liegt ihre
integration auch in unserem
strategischen interesse
es geht nicht allein um die sicherheit
dieser region in der externe kräfte um
einfluss ring nicht zuletzt russland es
geht um unsere eigene sicherheit die
ohne einen stabilen europäischen
westbalkan nicht zu haben ist
daher muss auch die eu jetzt gegen
liefern gegenüber dem westlichen balkan
und dafür setze ich mich ein indem ich
gespräche führe um fortschritte bei den
verhandlungen zu erreichen und auch
innerhalb der eu die letzten hindernisse
aus dem weg zu räumen indem wir den
sogenannten berliner prozess
wiederbeleben der die regionale
zusammenarbeit unter den sechs
westbalkanstaaten stärkt und in dem ich
noch vor dem europäischen rat im juni in
die region reisen mit der klaren
botschaft im gepäck der westliche balkan
gehört in die europäische union
viele kolleginnen und kollegen ein
weiteres thema wird uns bei unserem
gipfel in zehn tagen intensiv
beschäftigen und auch viele bürgerinnen
und bürger treibt es um es geht um die
sicherheit und unabhängigkeit unserer
energieversorgung
es geht um bezahlbare energie beides
müssen wir gewährleisten
national und europäisch und sowohl
national als auch europäisch behalten
wir eines immer im blick dass der von
russland verschuldete preisanstieg
niemanden überfordert wir lassen
niemanden allein
das gilt ganz besonders für die
bürgerinnen und bürger mit kleinem und
mittlerem einkommen
sie schwören tagtäglich das durch den
krieg nicht nur der sprit an der
zapfsäule teurer geworden ist sondern
auch lebensmittel vom brot bis zum
speisen
und auch betriebe die unter den
energiepreisen leiden und denen die
russland geschäft weggebrochen es können
sich auf unsere unterstützung verlassen
dafür stehen die beiden entlastungspaket
die wir schon beschlossen haben und die
in den nächsten wochen wirken die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage die energie
pauschale von 300 euro die zuschüsse für
familien wohngeldempfänger studierende
und sozialleistungsempfänger die
entlastung beim tanken das neun euro
ticket als anreiz stärker den
öffentlichen nahverkehr zu nutzen all
das kommt den bürgern und bürgern zugute
direkt schnell und zielgerichtet
und für die unterstützung dieser
maßnahmen durch den bundestag sage ich
herzlich danke
auf europäischer ebene geht es vor allem
darum sicherzustellen dass es keine
engpässe bei der energieversorgung in
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten geben das ist
ein gebot europäischer solidarität
teil einer europäischen lösung ist daher
auch der ausbau der transeuropäischen
energienetze
mittel und langfristig bleibt der einzig
vernünftige weg die einzig vernünftige
antwort auf die derzeitigen probleme am
energiemarkt dass wir uns unabhängig
machen von fossiler energie
dass wir dabei gemeinsam vorankommen in
europa hat mein gestriges treffen mit
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen aus
dänemark die niederlande belgien und
kommissionspräsidentin von allein im
dänischen esbjerg gezeigt
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck und
ich haben mit unseren kolleginnen
kollegen vereinbart die gewinnung und
nutzung von windenergie in der nordsee
gemeinsam noch viel stärker
voranzutreiben
die kommissionspräsident und hat dabei
ihre vorschläge erläutert um europa
unabhängiger von fossilen
energieimporten aus russland zu machen
und den übergang zur klimaneutralität
voranzubringen das ist eine wichtige
initiative der kommission
wir werden uns die vorschläge jetzt
rasch ansehen und darüber beim
außerordentlichen europäischen rat
beraten wir wollen dass davon impulse
ausgehen zur beschleunigung des ausbaus
der erneuerbaren energien für mehr
energieeffizienz und für die
industrielle transformation auf
das fiktive paket der eu spielt hier
eine entscheidende rolle es muss
vollständig verabschiedet werden so
schnell wie möglich unser ziel ist klar
wir wollen und wir werden die
souveränität europas auch in
energiefragen erhöhen und europas
klimaziele erreichen
die wir kolleginnen und kollegen nicht
nur an dieser stelle zeigt sich wie
tiefgreifend die folgen des russischen
krieges sind weit über die
sicherheitspolitik hinaus bei der
energieversorgung bei den
rohstoffpreisen
bei der weltweiten versorgung mit
nahrungsmitteln
viele länder in der welt müssen sich
sorgen machen wie das weitergeht
angesichts des kriegs in der ukraine und
in vielen anderen bereichen unseres
lebens
ich habe daher schon zu beginn des
russischen anders gesagt die folgen
dieses krieges treffen auch uns und
zugleich bin ich fest davon überzeugt
wir werden die folgen bewältigen hier
bei uns in europa und auch weltweit
weil wir ein starkes land sind mit
starken partnern und allianzen vor allem
aber weil wir wissen was wir verteidigen
frieden freiheit und
recht schönen dunk
hier soweit die regierungserklärung von
bundeskanzlern darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen die ukraine muss bestehen viele
haben ja vorher gefordert dass der
transfer jemand klartext reden soll
machen sich hier eigene meinung ob das
jetzt eine klare definition des ausgangs
dieses krieges darstellt er hat dann
noch einmal erklärt warum die 100
milliarden wichtig sein und hat am
schluss auch darauf hingewiesen dass
niemand allein gelassen werde bei den
preisanstiegen deswegen habe die
bundesregierung ja verschiedene
maßnahmen schon auf den weg gebracht auf
europäischer ebene gehe es darum
niemanden zurückzulassen bei der energie
keine engpässe in einzelnen ländern
aufkommen zu lassen wir müssen
solidarisch zusammenstehen und
unabhängig von fossiler energie werden
dass repower programm das gestern
vorgestellt wurde umgestellt das kannst
du ja auch noch einmal kurz viel applaus
aus den eigenen reihen und jetzt gibt es
eine 90 minütige aussprache und der
erste redner ist der oppositionschef der
chef der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
friedrich merz
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich werde mich nicht ein rein in eine
gruppe von leuten die für ein kurzes
rein und raus mit einem fototermin was
machen
das war
rund 120 tat zwar ein zitat des
bundeskanzlers aus einem interview auf
die frage wann er denn jetzt nach kiew
reisen wollte herr bundeskanzler wen
meinen sie denn mit dieser gruppe von
leuten
meinen sie damit
bei ihnen liegen aber nach dem letzten
wahlsonntag die nerven wirklich planen
frage sie nochmal der bundeskanzlerin
meinen sie denn mit sind ja jetzt
immerhin kleine jungs und mädels mehr
die sie da produzieren sondern eine
gruppe von leuten also ist dass die
bundestagspräsidentin oder sind das die
drei ausschussvorsitzenden ist dass der
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
ist dass nancy pelosi die sprecherin des
amerikanischen repräsentantenhauses sind
das die ministerpräsidenten aus polen
tschechien und slowenien oder ist es
etwa die bundes außenministerin die
heute aus guten gründen hier nicht dabei
sein kann sie sprechen immer so viel
auch in ihrer rede heute von respekt ich
möchte an dieser stelle einfach
denjenigen die aus deutschland der
bundes aussenministerin und der
bundestagspräsidentin einmal herzlich
dank sagen und respekt ausdrücken dass
sie diese reise gemacht haben herzlich
dankbar
auch aufschlussreich das kann nur die
unionsfraktion jetzt klar spricht aber
gut meine damen und herren die ukraine
braucht auch weiterhin die solidarität
der internationalen staatengemeinschaft
und das haben sie herr bundeskanzler mit
ihrer regierungserklärung heute richtig
und zutreffend zum ausdruck gebracht
dass brutale morgen an der bevölkerung
der ukraine und die sinnlose zerstörung
dieses landes durch die russischen
aggression gehen täglich weiter wir
begreifen jeden tag mehr wie furchtbar
dieser krieg ist und wie tief greifend
er die politische ordnung nicht nur in
europa sondern auf der ganzen welt
verändern wird vor diesem hintergrund
ist es gut und richtig dass die staats
und regierungschefs der europäischen
union in der übernächsten woche zu einem
außerordentlichen treffen zusammenkommen
der deutsche bundestag hat ihnen der
bundeskanzler auf dem weg dorthin in der
gemeinsamen entschließung die wir mit
großer mehrheit am 28 april
verabschiedet haben einen klaren
beschluss gegeben eine grundlage gegeben
welche schritte wir aus der mitte des
parlaments
hier in deutschland für richtig und für
notwendig halten wir wollen und wir
müssen dem land finanziell und humanitär
weiterhelfen und ich will an dieser
stelle
ein herzlich dank sagen an alle
humanitären organisationen in
deutschland aber auch an die vielen
familien die geflüchtete frauen mütter
mit ihren kindern aufnehmen in schutz
und zuflucht in deutschland gewähren
dies ist ein großartiges zeichen unseres
landes
wir wollen einvernehmlich hier in diesem
haus mit sanktionen dafür sorgen dass
dieses putin regime regime getroffen
wird dass der gesamte militärisch
industrielle komplex dieses landes so
hart wie möglich getroffen wird und
meine damen und herren ja auch das ist
konsens hier in diesem haus jedenfalls
in der politischen mitte dieses hauses
wir wollen und wir müssen der ukraine
mit waffen helfen damit dieses land sein
recht zur selbstverteidigung wahrnehmen
kann nun stellen sich allerdings
in diesem zusammenhang herr
bundeskanzler eine ganze reihe von
fragen sie haben hier richtigerweise in
ihrer regierungserklärung betont dass
mit diesen waffen lieferungen an die
ukraine keine eskalation dieses
konfliktes verbunden sind die
einschätzung teilen wir aber warum sagen
sie denn in interviews mehrfach
hintereinander
genau diesen sachverhalt und männern
waffenlieferungen aus europa und aus
deutschland als eine mögliche gefährdung
einer eskalation das passt doch nicht
zusammen was sie heute morgen wieder
gesagt haben und dass sie immer wieder
auch im interview zu diesem thema sagen
oder erwecken sie den eindruck dass
diese waffenlieferungen stattfinden die
wahrheit ist doch dass aus deutschland
in den letzten wochen so gut wie nichts
an waffen geliefert worden ist wir
wissen es doch wir können doch die
dokumente einsehen es wird praktisch
nichts geliefert stattdessen versprechen
sie den gepard das ist ein waffensystem
dass die ukraine gar nicht haben wollte
das ist das komplizierteste waffensystem
dass es überhaupt gibt und für dieses
waffensystem gibt es keine munition was
machen sie denn was treiben sie denn da
für ein spiel auch mit der deutschen
öffentlichkeit wenn es um diese waffen
liefern
sie sprechen sagt wochen sie sprechen
seit wochen von einem sogenannten hinter
der da von statten gehen soll der hat
bis heute nicht stattgefunden
sie erklären dass unternehmen die noch
waffensysteme auf ihren höfen stehen
haben liefern dürfen seit wochen
beklagen diese unternehmen mittlerweile
öffentlich dass sie die
exportgenehmigungen der bundesregierung
für diese waffenlieferungen nicht kommen
was ist da eigentlich los welches
doppelte spiel wird da eigentlich in
ihrer regierung betrieben meine damen
und herren ich bin geneigt ich bin
geneigt sein hof vater hier nochmal zu
zitieren der sie ich finde in diesem
zusammenhang gar nicht so unrecht gesagt
hat das problem sitzt im kanzleramt
meine damen und herren und so scheint es
die der tat zu sein
sie sprechen sie sprechen dann
gleichzeitig der
bundesverteidigungsministerium mit
ministerin ihr vertrauen aus einer
ministerin die seit wochen mehr mit
selbstverteidigung als mit
verteidigungspolitik beschäftigt ist und
am letzten wochenende am letzten
wochenende ist ein bericht in der presse
erschienen meine damen und herren der
nun endgültig belegt dass diese
ministerin das vertrauen der soldatinnen
und soldaten der bundeswehr nicht mehr
erreichen wird deswegen gebe ich ihnen
den rat trennen sie sich von dieser
ministerin so schnell wie möglich sie
werden es sowieso und in den nächsten
wochen und monaten machen müssen also
machen sie muss bald damit es mit der
bundeswehr auch wieder wirklich voran
gehen und vor diesem hintergrund vor
diesem hintergrund werden sie verstehen
dass wir im zusammenhang mit dem
vorschlag eines sondervermögens über 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
besonders sorgfältig umgehen ja wir sind
in gesprächen ob das gute gespräche sind
sei einmal dahin gestellt wir sind uns
jedenfalls bisher nicht einig gut sind
sie nur in einer hinsicht wir die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist die
einzige fraktion in diesem bundestag die
ihnen mit dem was sie gesagt haben in
ihrer regierungserklärung am 27 februar
nämlich 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr und dauerhaft mehr als zwei
prozent unseres bip in jedem jahr für
die verteidigung wir sind die einzige
fraktion die ihn in diesem weg
uneingeschränkt folgen will den
widerspruch muss nicht und uns den gibt
es auf ihren
fraktion herr bundeskanzler
sie haben sie haben angesprochen in
ihrer regierungserklärung das
beschaffungs system wir sind uns mit
ihnen einig dass wir daran etwas
wirklich grundlegendes ändern müssen wir
können diese 100 milliarden nicht noch
einmal so
wir sind uns einig mit ihnen was ist
denn daran auch drin ein zur aufregung
wir sind mit ihnen einig dass wir dieses
beschaffungs system ändern wollen ich
möchte nur heute fast drei monate
nachdem sie den vorschlag gemacht haben
einmal feststellen es gibt dazu aus
ihrer koalition bis heute keinen
einzigen vorschlag wie das denn gehen
soll also die beschwörung einer
notwendigkeit was da alles geändert
werden muss es das eine aber praktische
politik in der richtigen kompetenz des
bundeskanzlers sehen wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt bis heute nicht meine damen
und herren
und alaska abschließen
lassen sie mich abschließend einige
themen ansprechen die sie nur am rande
oder gar nicht angesprochen haben ja wir
sind der meinung dass der westbalkan in
die europäische union aufgenommen werden
sollte wir sind mit ihnen der meinung
dass die ukraine eine
beitrittsperspektive haben muss in die
europäische union aber was sagt denn die
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland auf diese frage sind sie für
einen kandidatenstatus der ukraine oder
sind sie es nicht das wäre doch eine
gute gelegenheit gewesen dass heute
morgen hier mal in deutschland sie sagen
wie stehen sie
wie stehen sie zu dem wunsch der ukraine
nach diesem krieg den wir hoffentlich
bald zu ende gehen sehen
sicherheitsgarantien auch aus
deutschland zu bekommen sind sie bereit
solche sicherheits garantien zu geben ja
oder nein die soll der wiederaufbau der
ukraine denn finanziert werden sie sagen
einen solidaritätsfonds damit können wir
uns durchaus anfreunden mit diesem
gedanken aber wie soll dieser
solidaritätsfonds denn finanziert werden
sind sie mit teilen der eu kommission
der auffassung dass dies mit
zusätzlichen neuen schulden der
europäischen union gemacht werden soll
oder sind sie dagegen sagen sie doch uns
ihre meinung zu diesen zentralen themen
um die es dann auch geht in der welt von
morgen nach diesem krieg und dann zwei
letzte anderen
der französische staatspräsident hat bei
seinem besuch hier in berlin ja
vorgeschlagen ein neues system der
integration der heranführung
verschiedener staaten an die europäische
union zu entwickeln er hat davon
gesprochen die demokratien der welt um
die europäische union herum zu einen wie
soll das denn gehen wir sind dafür dass
das stattfindet aber wie soll es denn
institutionell gingen sind sie der
meinung dass zum beispiel der
europäische wirtschaftsraum gestärkt
werden soll dass die etlicher weise ein
instrument sein könnte sind sie der
auffassung das assoziierungsabkommen mit
der europäischen union auf den weg
gebracht werden sollten diese
heranführung an die europäische union zu
ermöglichen und dann haben sie über eine
zuständigkeit der europäischen union
überhaupt nicht gesprochen die sie
nämlich neben der währungspolitik fast
ganz alleine hat aber auf die zustimmung
der mitgliedstaaten angewiesen mussten
kein wort über die handelspolitik
verloren meine damen und herren ja wir
brauchen energie wir brauchen gas
gebrochen kohle gebrauchen öl aus vielen
anderen ländern der welt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister ist in katar
unterwegs um gaslieferungen nach
deutschland zu ermöglichen aber warum um
gottes willen lehnen sie bis in diese
woche hinein die befassung des deutschen
bundestages mit dem fertig gestellten
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada immer
wieder ab gestern und so
fest dass
sich die mehrheit ihrer koalition
dieses abkommen auf die tagesordnung des
deutschen bundestages zu setzen es
weigert sich die mehrheit ihrer
koalition auch einmal über die frage zu
sprechen wie wir denn die
handelsbeziehungen zu den vereinigten
staaten von amerika weiter entwickeln
soll mit katar gaslieferungen zu machen
und mit kanada kein abkommen
abzuschließen über den freihandel herr
bundeskanzler ihre politik wird nicht
glaubwürdiger dadurch dass sie es auf
diese art und weise zu lassen und
schließlich zum schluss sie verloren
kein bock sie verlieren kein wort über
den umgang der europäischen union mit
den zwei größten ländern dieser welt
nämlich mit indien und mit china zwei
länder die sich im verein in der
vollversammlung der vereinten nationen
ihrer stimme enthalten haben als es um
die verurteilung der aggression in
russland wie soll diese europäische
union ihre beziehungen zu indien und
china den entwickeln angesichts dieser
weigerung sich auf die seite der
freiheitlichen und demokratischen
staaten der welt zu stellen darauf muss
europa doch eine antwort geben und
europa kann nur eine antwort geben dann
ist dazu eine vorstellung der
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland gibt ohne sie wird es nicht
gehen der bundeskanzler sie müssen dazu
etwas sagen
und deswegen lassen sie nicht lassen wir
nicht zu der schlussfolgerung kommen
denn wenn zeitenwende wirklich der
epochenwandel ist den sie in ihrer
regierungserklärung am 27 februar hier
von dieser stelle aus beschrieben haben
dann bleibt jedenfalls die heutige
regierungserklärung von ihnen weit
hinter den notwendigkeiten zurück um
eine solche epochenwende wirklich aktiv
zu gestalten
da muss mehr kommen herr bundeskanzler
das reicht nicht zum jetzt
soweit also der vortrag des
oppositionschefs scharfzüngig teilweise
polemisch prüfbericht märz hier den
bundeskanzler gleich zu anfang direkt an
da ging es erneut um die frage wann olaf
scholz wohl nach ihrer reise die ukraine
braucht solidarität der
startgemeinschaft wir wollen das land
finanziell humanitär und humanitär
helfen aber sie brauchen auch waffen und
die wahrheit ist so sagt zu durch märz
das viel über waffen gesprochen wird
aber aus der bundesrepublik noch keine
schwere waffen geliefert wurde auch beim
berühmten ringtausch ist es bisher über
ankündigungen noch nicht hinweg gegangen
dann hat für dich märz hier den
rücktritt der
verteidigungsministerium gefordert und
anton hofreiter zitierte sagte das
problem sitzt im kanzleramt
der die nächste rednerin kommt jetzt von
der fdp
eine der beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden in
dem fall katharina dröge hat jetzt das
wort in der aussprache
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr merz ich frage mich warum
ihre reden in diesen generale button
eigentlich immer beginnen wie bier
zertreten ich finde dass es der debatte
einfach nicht angemessen
wir sind hier sehr deutsche bundestag
wir tragen die verantwortung für dieses
land mitten in europa in einer zeit in
der der frieden in europa so sehr
herausgefordert wird wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht mehr es ist
unangemessen so zu beginnen es ist
angemessen damit zu beginnen was hier
wirklich vor uns liegt wir sind in einer
zeit in der iss die europäische union so
dringend braucht wie nie zuvor wir sind
in einer zeit in der es europäische
einigkeit geschlossenheit und
entschlossenheit so dringend braucht wie
nie zuvor angesichts der aggression von
putin angesichts eines krieges gegen die
ukraine der mit aller brutalität geführt
wird ist es so wichtig und richtig dass
die mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union hier gemeinsam und geschlossen
stehen
und ja
es sind keine einfachen entscheidung die
wir in diesen tagen treffen müssen und
ich verstehe jeden der angesicht dieser
entscheidung mit sich ringt aber
wenn man sich ernsthaft mit dem
auseinandersetzt was da in der ukraine
gerade passiert dann kann nicht handeln
keine option sein wer nicht handeln
heißt weiter zuzulassen was in butter
was in mario pohl und was in vielen
anderen orten in der ukraine
täglich passierten nicht zu handeln
heißt einen krieg zu lassen der keine
grenzen kennt ein krieg zuzulassen in
dem folter und vergewaltigung mittel des
krieges gegen die menschen in der
ukraine sind ein krieg zuzulassen in dem
nachdem der rückzug der russischen
truppen sichtbar wird die straßen von
leichen übersät sind diesen krieg
zulassen es sind weiter die
verschleppung von gefangenen von
kriegsgefangenen nach russland
zuzulassen mit einem ungewissen
schicksal
diesen krieg zuzulassen hieß das weiter
kinder von ihren eltern getrennt werden
und diesen krieg zulassen es auch
weiterhin einen präsidenten machen zu
lassen der selbst den globalen hunger
selbst die versorgung der ärmsten länder
dieser welt mit nahrungsmitteln so einem
mittels eines krieges gegen den rest der
welt gemacht hat und das ist wichtig und
richtig dass wir dem gemeinsam ein
stoppzeichen entgegensetzen
es ist unsere aufgabe das zu tun und es
war so wichtig dass die deutsche
außenministerin in der vergangenen woche
in kiel für die ganze bundesregierung
noch einmal deutlich gemacht hat wir
arbeiten jeden tag an weitere maßnahmen
an noch mehr unterstützung für die
ukraine unsere botschaft an putin ist
wir werden niemals aufhören die ukraine
zu unterstützen unsere unterstützung
gilt solange sie notwendig ist
und ja das heißt lieferung von schweben
lassen denn die ukraine muss sich
verteidigen können und das heißt weitere
wirtschaftliche sanktions pakete zu
beschließen 5 hat die europäische union
schon geschafft fünf mit denen wir
schnell entschlossen und konsequent
russland so weit es geht aus dem
globalen handel isoliert haben jetzt
steht ein sechstes sanktionspaket an
eines mit dem wir weitere russische
banken vom finanzsystem abkoppeln werden
und es steht auch an dass sich die
europäische union auf einen weg für ein
öl embargo einigt der die abkopplung von
fossilen importen aus russland ist das
stärkste instrument was wir
wirtschaftlich russland entgegensetzen
können
um jetzt auch eine zeit in der die
europäische union gezeigt hat was sie
kann sie hat gezeigt dass sie grenzen
öffnen kann sie hat gezeigt dass es
möglich ist in so einer krise die
menschen aus der ukraine
hierauf zu nehmen ihnen schutz zu bieten
einfach unbürokratisch schnell
unkompliziert und ich finde das muss der
maßstab sein auch dann wenn andere
menschen aus anderen regionen der welt
vor krieg terror und folter zu uns
fliegen dann muss die europäische union
diesen maßstab auch zum maßstab ihres
handelns machen
und ja wir müssen die ukraine
unterstützen auf ihrem weg in die
europäische union und ich bin sehr froh
dass der deutsche bundestag in der
letzten sitzungswoche dieses signal so
gemeinsam und entschlossen ausgesendet
hat denn die europäische union stellt
gerade jetzt für das gegenteil von dem
wofür russland steht die europäische
union ist ein projekt des friedens eine
gemeinschaft des rechts und eine
gemeinschaft gemeinsamer werte für uns
sind meinungsfreiheit demokratie und
menschenrechte das fundament auf dem wir
die europäische union aufgebaut haben
und das müssen wir jetzt umso dringender
verteidigen
und angesichts der russischen aggression
stehen wir auch in sicherheitsfragen
geschlossener zusammen denn je und
deshalb freue ich mich über die
entscheidung von finnland und schweden
jetzt der nato jetzt ein gemeinsam
sicherheitsbündnis beizutreten wir
werden hier im deutschen bundestag sie
schnell es geht handeln um diese weitere
zu ermöglichen und wir werden auch als
ampel fraktion jetzt in dieser zeit mehr
in unsere gemeinsame sicherheit so
investieren aber es geht um gemeinsame
sicherheit und deswegen finde ich es
völlig unverständlich dass sie
ausgerechnet in dieser zeit als unions
fraktion aus einer grundgesetzänderung
die dem deutschen bundestag vorliegt
dass wir kennen zur stärkung der
bündnisfähigkeit streichen wollen was
ist das für ein signal an die nato
partnerinnen das ist ein signal an die
länder die platte mitglied der nato
werden sollen dass das woraufhin der
nato unseres kollektiven und sicherheit
begründet haben dass ich das aus dieser
größte veränderung streichen wollen
sicherheit im 21 jahrhundert denkt man
nicht mehr national sondern gemeinsam
und es ist gleichzeitig das schicksal
dieser generation die heute politische
verantwortung trägt das mit zwei krisen
gleichzeitig lösen müssen auf der einen
seite müssen wir die frage der
sicherheit in europa beantworten und auf
der anderen seite nimmt die klimakrise
mit unbarmherziger geschwindigkeit zu
der blick nach indien und pakistan
menschen seit über zwei monaten unter
beispielloser held zu leiden zeigt wie
real die klimakrise jetzt schon ist wie
sehr der planet schon jetzt unter dem
leidet was wir durch unser handeln in
den letzten jahrzehnten verursacht haben
und deswegen ist es jetzt so dringend
zeit alles dafür zu tun um umzusteuern
untertassen unsere antworten sogar
zusammen denn die frage der energie
souveränität von europa ist gleichzeitig
auch eine frage der souveränität und
unabhängigkeit von fossilen und diese
frage müssen auch sie als union
beantworten zu diesem thema habe ich von
ihnen mit ihrer rede nichts gehört herr
merz jetzt ist die zeit um in zu
investieren gemeinsam in der
europäischen union in den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien jetzt ist die zeit
zu investieren in eine
wasserstoffwirtschaft die ärmsten machte
damit dass die wirtschaft auch umstellen
kann auf eine klimaneutrale produktion
jetzt ist die zeit zu investieren in
einen ausstieg aus fossilen gas das
thema energieeffizienz ist ein zentrales
klima thema aber es ist auch ein
zentrales wirtschaftsthema und das
müssen wir gemeinsam europäisch
beantworten
und ja wir ernst meint mit der
unabhängigkeit von russland der muss
auch mit der deutschen wirtschaft
ernsthaft sprechen denn der glaube dass
wir irgendwann in den nächsten zwei oder
drei jahren wieder anfangen können damit
gas oder kohle oder öl aus russland zu
kaufen den muss ich ihnen nehmen es ist
die klare ansage stellen sie sich darauf
ein wir werden nie wieder so abhängig
von fossilen aus russland werden nie
wieder so abhängig von gas aus russland
und darauf müssen sie sich vorbereiten
das heißt was die kadetten ich weiß dass
das wird nicht einschlafen können über
politische unterstützung reden aber
glauben sie nicht daran dass wir auf
diesem weg noch einmal umkehren werden
das schulden wir der sicherheit in
europa das schulden wir auch der zukunft
unserer kinder mit blick auf die
unabhängigkeit von fossilen und das ist
die gemeinsame antwort die sie und wir
zusammen geben müssen
hatte in der 3 die fraktionsvorsitzenden
der grünen rückte zu anfang friedrich
merz als sie bierzelt redner sie hatte
eine klare botschaft an herrn putin wir
werden niemals aufhören die ukraine zu
unterstützen ja auch mit lieferungen von
schweren waffen und weiteren
sanktionspaket hat sie gesagt und am
ende hat sie noch einmal ausgeführt die
energiefrage die frage der energie
souveränität von europa ist auch die
frage der unabhängigkeit von fossilen
brennstoffen hat sie gesagt und alice
weidl die fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
deutschland steckt politisch
wirtschaftlich und finanziell in einer
der schwersten krisen seit dem 2
die inflation ist dauerhaft auf hohem
niveau angekommen und stranguliert
mittelstand und mittelschicht das wurde
heute mit keinem wort erwähnt unsere
energieversorgung steht auf der kippe im
herbst droht ein
zusammenbruch
die migrations krise ist ungelöste
ansturm illegaler immigration übers
mittelmeer und über die land routen
erreichen neuer höchststände der
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine ist ein katalysator der die
krise zugespitzt hat und die defizite
unserer militär und sicherheitspolitik
offen liegt und dass ihre koalition
sich nicht einmal darauf einigen kann
für die bundeswehr
vorgesehenen 100 milliarden tatsächlich
in unsere eigene armee zu stecken zeigt
dass die botschaft noch immer nicht bei
ihnen angekommen ist und die ursache
der krise ist aber eine ganz andere und
zwar eine falsche fehlgeleitete politik
die energiewende hat mit dem
gleichzeitigen ausstieg aus atomkraft
und kohle nutzung die energie preise
hochgetrieben und die einseitige
abhängigkeit von russischem erdgas erst
verursacht sie saßen in der regierung
kanzler chance
verantwortungslose schuldenpolitik
verbotene monetäre staatsfinanzierung
die null zinspolitik der ezb
infolge dessen die abwertung des euros
und dadurch erhöhte importpreise sind
doch die eigentliche ursache der
inflation auch das wurde heute nicht
erwähnt die repressive corona politik
und undurchdachte sanktionen haben
lieferketten zerbrochen und das angebot
verknappt während die geldmenge
explodieren der verfall des euros rauch
den bürgern kaufkraft und wohlstand
härtere klimaziele und der forcierte
ausbau sogenannter
erneuerbarer energien werden uns nicht
unabhängiger machen sondern die energie
krise sogar noch verschärfen
härtere klimaziele
werden unseren haushalt plündern sie
werden unseren haushalt so belasten wie
wir es noch nicht gesehen habe und sie
werden nicht weitermachen können mit den
schulden den schulden staatliche
schulden heizen inflation immer mehr an
und verdrängen die private nachfrage die
russland sanktionspaket sind
kontraproduktiv sie schaden deutschland
und europa mehr als russland
öl und gas embargo gegen russland wäre
vollends ruinös denn ein tragfähiger
ersatz für die ausfallenden lieferung
steht in den sternen
hochgefährlich sind pläne das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip in zentralen
fragen abzuschaffen das ist eine
antidemokratische entmündigung der
nationalstaat
gemeinsam schulden für den wiederaufbau
der ukraine sind nichts anderes als ein
weiterer ausbau der schuldenunion zu
lasten der deutschen steuerzahler
und unter dem deckmantel des kampfes
gegen desinformation und missbrauch
betreibt die eu die totalüberwachung der
privaten kommunikation
und darüber hinaus plant man auch noch
ein eu-weites vermögens register um alle
privaten besitztümer zu erfassen das ist
ein weiterer schritt zur enteignung der
bürger um ihnen die flucht aus dem
verfallenden inflations geld in
sachwerte zu verbauen herr bundeskanzler
wenn sie zum eu ratstreffen fahren dann
lautet ihre vornehmste pflicht deutsche
interessen zu wahren und diesen
bestrebungen entgegen zu treten träumen
sie der bekämpfung der inflation und der
sicherung der energieversorgung
oberste priorität ein die inflation
beraubt die bürger sie ist die
unsozialste aller steuern sie ist eine
kalte vermögenssteuer die vor allem die
arbeitende und produktive mit der
wirtschaft und gesellschaft trifft
inflation bekämpft man nicht mit
umverteilung sondern mit weniger
schulden
steuersenkung und konzentration auf
strategische kernaufgaben des staates
verlassen sie also der weg der
energiewende sorgen sie dafür dass kohle
und kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen und
abgeschaltete reaktoren wieder
hochgefahren werden denn laut eu ist
atomkraft grün und co2 neutral und vor
allem tun sie alles um den krieg in
europa schnell zu beenden wir teilen
ihre sorge einer eskalation sie haben
festgestellt dass russland nicht
gewinnen darf aber als atommacht auch
nicht in eine ausweglose lage gedrängt
werden sollte der krieg in der ukraine
ist nicht unser krieg wir dürfen uns von
parolen propaganda und emotionen nicht
fort reißen lassen sondern müssen unsere
eigenen interessen vertreten und die
sind waffenstillstand und frieden der
ukraine krieg hat ein stadium erreicht
in dem statt ständig neuer
waffenlieferungen der verhandlungsweg
beschritten werden muss um einen
jahrelangen abnutzungskrieg zu
verhindern und stellen sie sich den
extremen grünen gefühls politikern
entgegen die vom infantilen pazifismus
umstandslos auf moralisierende polizist
muss umgeschaltet haben und erinnern sie
ihre minister daran dass inhaltsleere
phrasen noch keine außenpolitik sind wer
nach kia fährt muss auch nach moskau
fahren um gesprächsfaden wieder
aufzunehmen beschreiten sie bitte den
weg der vernunft vielen herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion
christian dürr
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen
84 tage krieg in der ukraine
man befürchtet 10.000 tote zivilistinnen
und zivilisten
mindestens 10.000 tote ukrainische
soldaten und über 15.000 verwunderte 13
millionen geflüchtete oder vertriebene
im eigenen land über 30 prozent der
infrastruktur der ukraine sind zerstört
die lage in der ukraine ist eine
tragödie der angriffskrieg russlands
bleibt meine damen und herren für immer
unentschuldbar und ich sage 1 an dieser
stelle wir dürfen uns an die bilder aus
der ukraine nicht gewöhnen wir
das sage ich insbesondere vor dem
hintergrund der rede meiner vorrednerin
wir in deutschland die europäische union
der gesamte westen wir müssen alles tun
was wir können um diesen krieg zu
beenden und die integrität der ukraine
wieder herzustellen meine damen und
herren das ist humanitäre verpflichtung
jeden kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist jetzt gerade unsere aufgabe
die europäischen werte der freiheit der
selbstbestimmung und der
wirtschaftlichen eigenständigkeit
aufzuzeigen wir teilen diese werte mit
den ukrainerinnen und ukrainer und
deshalb ist es das richtige zeichen
meine damen und herren der ukraine jetzt
den europäischen weg aufzuzeigen auch
das will ich deutlich sagen
die konsequenzen dieses krieges für die
internationale ordnung sind dramatisch
denn das alte kommt nicht wieder die
alte welt auch die alten beziehung zu
russland werden so nicht wiederkommen es
geschieht übrigens nun das was russland
immer verhindern wollte wir stehen als
westliche verbündete zusammen dass
schweden und finnland jetzt den beitritt
zur nato beantragt haben meine damen und
herren ist ein richtiges und gutes
zeichen wir heißen findet und schweden
in der nato sehr herzlich willkommen
auch das muss deutlich gesagt werden
und was uns als europäer europäer was
uns als europäische union jetzt auch in
dieser phase so wichtig ist dass wir die
richtigen zeichen setzen dass bereits
vorgesehene öl-embargo müssen wir jetzt
gemeinsam durchsetzen sowohl der
entsprechende beschluss der g7 staaten
als auch die bemühungen der eu aus
russischen öl auszusteigen ist das
richtige zeichen der beschluss des
europäischen ausstiegs und die
unabhängigkeit von russischen
rohstoffimporten ist ein meilenstein
es geht jetzt alles dafür zu tun diesen
beschluss umzusetzen so schnell es geht
es kommt uns als europäerin europäern
jetzt eine ganz entscheidende rolle zu
auch in der welt nicht nur innerhalb der
europäischen union wir müssen darüber
hinaus sehen denn die auswirkungen des
krieges gehen weit über europa hinaus
es ist daher die globale verantwortung
der eu insbesondere jetzt auch das thema
nahrungsmittelknappheit in der welt zu
adressieren in europa beobachten wir
eine starke inflation
anderswo bedeutet dieser krieg eine
existenzielle ernährungskrise 47
millionen menschen sind zusätzlich vom
hunger bedroht auch der hunger in der
welt meine damen und herren auch das
will ich sagen der hunger in der welt
ist eine waffe russlands in diesem krieg
wir müssen verstehen dass was hier als
inflation daherkommt ganz konkret
woanders hunger bedeutet meine damen und
herren wir sollten gerade als
europäische union und deutschland
unseren beitrag dazu leisten wir haben
in europa in deutschland eine sehr
starke landwirtschaft auch die brauchen
wir jetzt an dieser stelle es geht um
die ernährungssicherheit in diesem
sommer in der gesamten welt liebe
kollegen verlegt
und es wird etwas zweites für die
zukunft ansprechen ist wird jetzt auch
bei den verabredungen innerhalb europas
um die frage des wiederaufbaus der
ukraine gehen die direkte finanzielle
und militärische unterstützung steht
jetzt selbstverständlich im vordergrund
aber die lieferung von waffen die jetzt
wichtig ist das hat ja ein ziel meine
damen und herren jetzt schwere waffen zu
liefern wofür ich der bundesregierung
sehr dankbar bin dass diese entscheidung
aus der mitte des hauses eben auch in
der bundesregierung getroffen worden ist
das hat ein ziel ich will das sind aller
kleid sagen ich sprach von über die
integrität der ukraine aber wir müssen
auch jetzt darüber hinaus blickt nämlich
den aufbau der ukraine insgesamt meine
damen und herren wenn wir davon reden
dass die europäische freiheit in der
ukraine verteidigt wird dann müssen wir
auch sagen wofür nämlich dass menschen
dort in zukunft in wohlstand leben
können das ist das ziel der menschen in
der ukraine
wir wollen dass die ukraine wieder
freies was wir uns immer bewusst machen
müssen die menschen in der ukraine
kämpfen verein danach in freiheit und
wohlstand meine damen und herren dabei
unterstützen wir sind
und dabei kommt uns jetzt natürlich
unsere wirtschaftliche stärke als westen
und deutschland zugute diese
wirtschaftliche stärke ist zurzeit auch
unsere geopolitische stärke meine damen
und herren und herr kollege merz ich
will dass zum schluss meiner rede sagen
all das was sie hier gesagt haben war
weniger eine abrechnung mit der
bundesregierung es war eine abrechnung
mit ihrer eigenen
regierungsverantwortung als cdu und csu
das war schon wahrheit das war's in
wahrheit wissen sie herr merz ich hätte
mir
etwas anderes gewünscht man selbst 16
jahre verantwortung für die bundeswehr
und für die soldatinnen und soldaten in
deutschland getragen hat ich hätte nie
etwas anderes gewünscht meine damen und
herren etwas anderes gewünscht wenn man
selbst das 2 prozent ziehen in
regierungsverantwortung fast nie er weg
und in jedem fall haushalterischen die
hochgehalten hat liebe kollegen kollegen
und ich hätte mir
ich hätte mir ich hätte mir etwas
anderes gewünscht auch vor dem
hintergrund dass sie in wahrheit jetzt
ja zum glück mit dem beitritt zu unserem
antrag zum thema waffenlieferung
beitrittsperspektive und so weiter in
der vorvergangenen woche einen anderen
kurs eingeschlagen haben und jetzt
glücklicherweise entschieden haben als
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion bei einer
verfassungsänderung ein abzählreim er
aufzuführen herr kollege märt ich will
eins sagen
ich bin ich will eines zum schluss sagen
wir haben hier tatsächlich eine
zeitenwende eingeleitet als
ampelkoalition wir liefern waffen in
kriegsgebiete wir brechen die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit einem
ehemaligen handelspartner ab wie
investieren massiv in unserer armee das
hat es vorher nicht gegeben periklis hat
mal gesagt der schlüssel zum glück ist
die freiheit der schlüssel zur freiheit
ist der mut sein wir gemeinsam mutig ich
danke ihnen
der fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp hat am
anfang die völlig richtigen worte
gefunden will dürfen uns an die bilder
in der ukraine nicht gewöhnen wie in
deutschland in europa in der gesamten
westlichen welt müssen alles tun um den
krieg zu beenden
und während hier die debatte läuft gibt
es auch woanders politische entwicklung
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat soeben
entschieden dass die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht statthaft ist so
amir amor mit molly jetzt die
fraktionsvorsitzende linksfraktion
angriff russlands
jeden tag unvorstellbares leid so viele
menschen sind schon gestorben tausende
stehen vor den scherben ihrer existenz
tausende sind auf der flucht ihnen
gehört unsere unumstößliche solidarität
und da
danke vor allem denjenigen die jetzt
große hilfsbereitschaft zeigen die sich
selbstlos einsätzen für diese menschen
in not ist es so wichtig klar ist dieser
krieg muss so schnell wie möglich
beendet werden und klar ist auch putin
darf ihn nicht gewinnen
aber wer ernsthaft glaubt dass man
russland die größte atommacht der welt
mit militärischen mitteln in die knie
zwingen kann der irrt einfach im
gegenteil das ist ein hochgefährlicher
kurs
oft wird in der aktuellen debatte aber
leider so getan als gäbe es nur die
alternative zwischen militärische musik
und kapitulation der ukraine die
erlebnis sogar immer wieder dass
diejenigen die wir sofort wieder
diplomatische bemühungen auch nur
sprechen dass die in die nähe putins
gerückt werden besonders wenn das
politisch passt aber das ist doch
quatsch diese art auseinandersetzung die
hilft doch nicht weiter und sie hilft
vor allem nicht wenn leidtragende
menschen ukraine dass die wahrheit
sieht der italienische premierminister
mario draghi der hat doch recht wenn er
auf friedensverhandlungen drängt und ja
ich weiss friedensverhandlungen die
brauchen die bereitschaft einen
kompromiss zu finden und ein kompromiss
zu finden wo russland doch die ukraine
überfallen hat das widerspricht dem
gerechtigkeitsempfinden auch meinem
eigenen natürlich aber es kann doch
trifft den britischen premier
beschlossen nicht zustimmen wenn er sagt
mit putin gäbe es nichts zu verhandeln
wenn was ist denn die alternative zu
diplomatischen lösungen es ist ein immer
länger dauernder krieg mit immer mehr
toten das ist die wachsende gefahr einer
ausweitung des krieges die gefahr eines
dritten weltkrieges und das darf doch
nicht sein kollege noko lebt
es heißt oft die türen für diplomatische
lösung die wären aktuell verschlossen
aber frau werbung da möchte ich sie mal
fragen wie viele klinken haben sie den
bisher eigentlich ernsthaft probiert
warum wahnsinnig in peking oder neu
geben ich habe manchmal den eindruck
überwechseln du wirklich riesen ressort
sie zuständig sind sie sind nicht die
verteidigungsminister sie sind die
außenministerin die chefdiplomatin und
da erwarte ich auch diplomat ihnen von
ihnen
deutschland muss gemeinsam mit regen
endlich zu stimme der vernunft werben
und das kann die eu lehnen wir uns an
dem fünf tage krieg um südossetien
zwischen georgien und russland im jahr
2008 nach ist eine extrem schwierige
situation die vereinten nationen waren
mit ihren bemühungen bereits gescheitert
ist war die eu die ein kompromiss
vermittelte bei dem treffen des
europäischen päischen rates sollte es
daher vor allem um gemeinsame
diplomatische anstrengungen ging
vergessen wird es aber vor allem um
sanktionen gehen aber nicht im
schwerpunkt um sanktionen gegen die
russische führung gegen die mächtigen
oligarchen das wäre richtig und auch
wichtig sondern um allgemeine sanktionen
die in russland vor allem die
bevölkerung treffen und die schon jetzt
in deutschland und der eu einen enormen
wirtschaftlichen schaden anrichten eben
weil diese sanktionen und vor allem die
eigene wirtschaft und damit die eigene
bevölkerung so hart treffen machen viele
länder dabei auch nicht mit und sie
kritisieren die sanktionspolitik der eu
schauen wir nach südamerika nach
südafrika nach indien ich kann verstehen
dass viele menschen angst bekommen in
deutschland wenn sie von geplant und öl
embargo hören weil sie fürchten dass die
lebenshaltungskosten dann noch weiter
steigen oder ist doch jetzt schon so
dass so manche friseurin sich am ende
des monats kein frisches obst mehr für
ihre kinder leisten kann er scheut sie
behaupten immer das wäre nicht so
ignorieren ihre not seenot ist aber die
realität das müssen sie mal zur kenntnis
und
ich kann verstehen dass viele menschen
ihre arbeitsplätze haben gehen sie mal
nach schwedt die raffinerie dort die ist
auf das rohöl aus russland angewiesen da
kann man sich ganz gut das hat der
politiker nicht einfach hinstellen und
sagen ja das nun mal der preis der
freiheit das doch wirklich zynisch sie
haben verantwortung für die menschen in
unserem land besonders für die die jetzt
schon kaum wissen über die runden kommen
sollen fakt ist doch ihre
entlastungspläne sie heute wieder
angepriesen haben die decken nicht mal
im ansatz die real mehrkosten ab und das
ist auf uns zukommen wird euch ein öl
embargo ist doch um ein vielfaches
gravierender da helfen keine
lippenbekenntnisse und keine
durchhalteparolen es braucht konsequente
maßnahmen zum beispiel die senkung von
verbrauch steuern auf
grundnahrungsmittel eine funktionierende
staatliche preisaufsicht für die energie
wesentlich höhere direktzahlungen es
braucht einen schutzschirm wir betroffen
unternehmen besonders im osten damit
nicht zum zweiten mal nach der wende im
osten reihenweise existenzen zerstört
werden dafür wäre es dringend notwendig
geld in die hand zu nehmen und zwar
wirklich viel geld und nicht in das
sinnlose sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr was nur ein effekt haben wird
nämlich die aktienkurse der
rüstungsindustrie in die höhe zu treiben
da machen wir als linke nicht mit
mohammed ali kritisierte unter anderem
die entlastungs päckchen die für die
einzelnen menschen nicht ausreichen der
bundeskanzler soll es sich um diese
menschen kümmern und am schluss haben
sie es gehört die unter milliarden wird
von der linken abgelehnt für die
bundeswehr achim post jetzt
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der spd fraktion frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren wir
reden ja heute über den europäischen rat
in einer ganz besonderen situation
in einer situation die ich jedenfalls
noch nicht erlebt haben
und wir reden in deutschland und europa
über
einen brutalen angriffskrieg putins auch
die ukraine mit schon jetzt tausenden
und abertausenden von opfern
in den letzten
hunderten von jahren in hunderten von
jahren war europa stets ein kontinent
des krieges durch die europäische union
durch die europäische einigung durch den
europäischen zusammenhalt
ist europa nach dem zweiten weltkrieg zu
einem kontinent des friedens geworden
und das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sollten wir uns immer vor augen halten
wenn wir hier über das eine oder andere
innenpolitische scharmützel reden das
ist aus meiner sicht nämlich auch nicht
angemessen bei dem passiert diskutiert
werden
und nach dem wieso friedensordnung vor
30 jahren durch die balkankriege im
ehemaligen jugoslawien zerstört wurde
wird sie jetzt gerade zerstört durch
putin und seinem brutalen angriffs
kriegen ich halte es für die richtige
die angemessene reaktion wenn der
bundeskanzler sagt er fährt auch diesen
gipfel mit klaren zielen mit dem ziel
europa zu stärken mit dem ziel europas
sicherheitspolitik zu stärken mit dem
ziel europas demokratie zu stärken und
wird diesen kurs diebe kollege und
kollegen hat der bundeskanzler und hat
die gesamte bundesregierung die
unterstützung der gesamten spd
bundestagsfraktion
und worauf kommt es an worauf kommt es
jetzt an in der europäischen union es
kommt an auf handlungsfähigkeit und
zusammenhalt und ich finde die häufig zu
unrecht viel gescholtene europäische
union hat in den letzten wochen hat in
den letzten zehn zwölf wochen die
handlungsfähigkeit an den tag gelegt mit
wirtschaftshilfen mit humanitärer hilfe
mit der aufnahme von flüchtlingen mit
waffenlieferungen mit unzähligen
initiativen führt diplomatie in richtung
waffenstillstand und auch mit einem
sanktionspaket mit mehreren
sanktionspaket die ihresgleichen suchen
und die wirken und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist es richtig
dass wir auf dem europäischen rat über
dinge reden über die wir früher nie
geredet hätten aber das machen wir das
wird der bundeskanzler machen und die
bundesregierung ich finde es richtig
dass auf der tagesordnung des nächsten
rates steht ein öl-embargo gegen
russland so schwer einem was auffällt es
gibt dazu wenig alternativen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich finde es
auch richtig dass nicht auf der
tagesordnung steht ein gas embargo denn
bei allen sanktionen und das hat der
bundeskanzler betonte geht es darum dass
es vor allen dingen putin schadet vor
allen dingen russland schadet und nicht
uns selbst und deshalb ist das was der
bundeskanzler vorgetragen hat genau der
richtige kurs der volle unterstützung
des gesamten hauses verdienen
und ich finde es richtig
und klug
dass auf dem gipfel darüber geredet wird
wie die europäische sicherheit und
verteidigungsfähigkeit gestärkt wird
hier wurde angesprochen schweden und
finnland schweden war 200 jahre lang
neutrale finnland gehörte länger zum
russischen zarenreich als es
eigenständig ist diese beiden länder
unter der führung zweier
regierungschefin und ministerpräsidentin
habe in zehn wochen gezeigt was eine
zeitenwende bedeutet sie haben nämlich
all das was sie hundert oder zweihundert
jahre für richtig gehalten haben über
bord geworfen das ist eine völlig neue
bedrohungen in europa gibt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und der bundeskanzler darauf hingewiesen
auf diesem rat muss und wird auch
darüber geredet wie es eigentlich mit
der beitrittsperspektive für den
westlichen balkan aussieht und was aus
dem versprechen geworden ist die die
europäische union und die viele
regierungen in europa seit vielen jahren
den mitgliedern des westlichen balkans
machen ich bin dafür dass man die
versprechungen in realitäten umsetzt und
schritt für schritt die länder des
westlichen balkans in die europäische
integration in die europäische union
integriert sauber ist es allerhöchste
zeit
und wenn wir über die ukraine reden
wer für europa europa und die ukraine
reden das ist doch klar und ich sehe
hier gar nicht so viele unterschiede
dass wir tatkräftig den weg der ukraine
in die europäische union unterstützen
werden liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn man darüber redet weichen
richtig zu stellen wenn man darüber
redet weichen richtig zu stellen und das
muss man heute machen damit europa auf
morgen weiter stark ist dann ist es gut
dass wir eine zukunftskonferenz
europäische union hatten und haben mit
vielen guten vorschlägen mit vielen
guten vorschlägen die wir uns alle
anschauen werden und zwar so schnell wie
möglich denn ich glaube das ist nötig
ist dass es notwendig ist das ist
geboten ist es ist zeitgemäß ist in der
europäischen union einige dinge zu
verbessern auch für mehr integration zu
sorgen wenn das innerhalb der verträge
geht wunderbar dann machen wir das
innerhalb der verträge wenn es nötig ist
außerhalb der verträge zu machen dann
machen wir das außerhalb der verträge
und organisieren über einen konvent neue
möglichkeiten für das weitere
zusammenwachsen der europäischen union
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zusammen gefasst es steht viel auf dem
spiel
und jeder oppositionsführer jede
oppositionsführerin kann hier zum glück
sagen was er oder was sie will denn das
ist ein freies land ein freies parlament
aber jeder muss auch wissen was er hier
sagt in einer solchen situation wo mehr
auf dem spiel steht als die nächste
kommunalwahl irgendwo in deutschland
steht auf dem spiel frieden und
sicherheit in erbach schulen danken
achim post war das der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
spd-bundestagsfraktion
sich trainer alexander dobrindt
landesgruppenchef der csu und
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der cdu/csu-fraktion ende sehr geehrte
damen und herren
der europäischen rates mit großen
erwartungen verbunden dass dort themen
auf der agenda stehen die die
europäische zukunft auf jahre hinaus
prägen werden ja und es wird darum gehen
wie man mit den folgen des krieges in
der ukraine umgehen muss mit
finanzieller unterstützung mit
notwendigen waffenlieferung mit
humanitärer unterstützung ja dass es
alles zwingend notwendig aber es wird
auch darüber gehen wie wir ein neues
sicherheits gleichgewicht in europa
schaffen können wie wir zukünftige
kriege vermeiden lieber die einheit
europas sichert wie wir stabilität neue
schaffen können und da haben wir zu
wenig gehört heute herr bundeskanzler
sie haben den französischen präsidenten
makro zitiert er angekündigt hat dass er
auf diesem rat über institutionelle
reformen der eu sprechen will herr
bundeskanzler sie haben gesagt ja das
sei kein tabu darüber zu sprechen aber
sie haben uns nicht gesagt wie ihre
vorschläge sind makros sagt
wirtschaftwachstum klima soziale fragen
und die erweiterung der eu sind sein
thema von ihnen kennen wir nur das
bekenntnis zu einer europäischen
schulden union und einer europäischen
arbeitslosenversicherung beides ist
schlichtweg falsch wir brauchen keine
schulden union wir brauchen keine
europäische arbeitslosenversicherung das
was wir brauchen ist eine neue kultur
der stabilität und eine ambitionierte
europäische verteidigung zwischen
darüber hätten wir von ihm nie etwas
gehört
wir brauchen auf diesem europäischen rat
die debatte über neue
sicherheitsgarantien
sicherheitsgarantien bei der frage der
militärischen zusammenarbeit und rüstung
inflationsbekämpfung und
wohlstandssicherung und
sicherheitsgarantien bei der
weiterentwicklung einer europäischen
union ohne dass sie überdehnt wird und
dass eine teilhabe an dem
friedensprojekt eu möglich ist außerhalb
einer vollmitgliedschaft darüber hätten
wir gerne etwas gehört beispielsweise
bei der sicherheit der militärischen
zusammenarbeit ja es ist richtig ein
baustein für die rüstung und für die
sicherheit sind ihre ankündigungen aus
ihrer rede der zeitenwende vom 27
februar sie haben da gesprochen vom
sondervermögen bundeswehr von das
vorhaben und von der dauerhaften
einhaltung des zwei prozent ziels herr
bundeskanzler
heute haben sie
das zwei prozent ziel in ihrer rede
nicht mehr erwähnt ich hoffe das war nur
ein versehen sie haben hier an dieser
stelle ein doppel versprechen abgegeben
100 milliarden euro und die zwei prozent
ich hoffe dass das kein hinweis heute
war dass ihre historische rede vom 27
februar bereits geschichte ist meine
damen und herren
ja es ist richtig wir befinden uns
aktuell auch in gesprächen
ich darf ihnen aber an der stelle herr
bundeskanzler auch sagen dass es noch
kein stück papier gibt auf dem steht das
100 milliarden euro für die streitkräfte
ins grundgesetz geschrieben werden und
zwei prozent jedes jahr zur erfüllung
der nato quote vereinbart sind das liegt
schlichtweg nicht an uns und liebe
kollegin dröge wenn es um die
bündnisfähigkeit geht dann lassen sie
sich bitte sagen nichts stärkt mehr
unsere bündnisfähigkeit als 100
milliarden in die streitkräfte zu
stecken das ist die aufgabe die dahinter
stehen
und ich will an dieser stelle auch damit
sie nicht als fraktionsvorsitzender der
spd haben sie diese woche sich
öffentlich geäußert und in bezug auf 100
milliarden und 2 prozent ziel davon
gesprochen dass die union von ihren
maximalforderungen abstand nehmen sollte
wir stellen keine maximalforderungen
aber wir erwarten dass das was der
bundeskanzler der öffentlichkeit
versprochen hat von den ampel
koalitionären mindestens eingehalten
wird das erraten wie an dieser stelle
es geht um sicherheitsgarantien für die
inflationsbekämpfung und die
bestandssicherung die inflation
entwickelt sich zur massiven gefahr für
wachstum und wohlstand in europa in
deutschland mit über 7 prozent in
unseren nachbarländern in europa
mittlerweile bei deutlich über zehn
prozent weil der damen und herren die
inflation in europa ist die stille
enteignung der sparer die stille
entwertung der kleinen und mittleren
einkommen der bundeskanzler die usa hat
den kampf gegen die inflation zum
topthema der amerikanischen innenpolitik
gemacht sie reden gerne vom sozialen
europa ich sage ihnen die steigende
inflation schafft ein unsoziales in
europa deswegen machen den sie
bekämpfung zum top thema ritter
und wir brauchen auch eine
sicherheitsgarantie bezüglich der frage
der fortentwicklung der europäischen
union ja die sicherheitspolitische lage
die sich verändert hat führt dazu dass
zunehmend auch neue länder schnell in
die europäische union beitreten wollen
die sechs balkanstaaten haben sie
genannt sie haben unsere unterstützung
ukraine moldau georgien stehen an der
schwelle wir müssen auch darauf achten
dass wir die europäische union nicht
überfordern ja es braucht eine
perspektive für diese länder ukraine
moldau georgien ja aber wir wissen dass
beitrittsverhandlungen jahre und
teilweise jahrzehnte dauern es ist jetzt
ihre aufgabe eine neue perspektive auch
für diese länder zu schaffen ich sagen
es braucht jetzt bei diesem rat eine
verhandlung darüber wie wir eine
beitrittsperspektive zum friedensprojekt
europäische union schaffen können ohne
dabei mit einer vollmitgliedschaft die
europäische union zu überdehnen da haben
sie eine aufgabe und da erwarten wir
schon in einer antwort herzlichen dank
der bundestag debattiert hier nach der
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
zum europäischen rat ende mai alexander
dobrindt war das der landesgruppenchef
der csu und jetzt als nächste erhält
hier das wort tobin wagner von den
bündnisgrünen es europapolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen letzte woche montag am 9
schauten wir alle nach moskau wir
schauen wir auf den roten platz und
sahen eine armada von soldaten wir sahen
bilder von langen panzerkolonne wir
sagen mit raketen bestückte bestückte
militärfahrzeuge und eingebettet in
diesem martialischen rahmen hörten wir
wladimir putin wie er den brutalen
angriffs krieg in der ukraine mit dem
zweiten weltkrieg verliert
das zeigt nicht nur seinen
menschenverachtenden zynismus sondern
das ist blanker hohn gegenüber den
opfern des zweiten weltkriegs und den
opfern des russischen angriff
dieser tag in moskau war gewiss kein tag
des sieges er war ein tag der niederlage
denn putin wird niemals die ukraine
besiegen aber etwas anderes wird er auch
niemals siegen und das ist der
unbedingte wille in ganz europa frieden
und freiheit demokratie und wohlstand zu
schaffen
und diesen unbedingten willen brachte am
9 mai am europatag fach zeitgleich mit
putins propaganda rede der französische
präsident immer nur im makro zum
ausdruck
präsident marc brown sprach nicht vor
soldaten mit waffen nicht vor
langstreckenraketen er sprach im herzen
der europäischen demokratie im
europaparlament in straßburg vor
hunderten bürgerinnen und bürgern aus
der gesamten europäischen union
und es war nicht nur im herzen der
demokratie es war auch ein fest der
demokratie wenn der diesjährigen
europatag markierte den abschluss der
konferenz zur zukunft der europäischen
union und das klingt erstmal schwierig
aber es ist historisch beispiellos ein
jahr lang haben über 800 bürgerinnen und
bürger aus der gesamten europäischen
union mit kommissionsmitgliedern mit
parlamentarierinnen mit
regierungsvertreterin über die zukunft
der europäischen union diskutiert
und die ergebnisse dieser diskussionen
die können sich sehen lassen und sie
kommen genau zur richtigen zeit denn ja
wir leben in einer zeitenwende und diese
neue zeit braucht auch neue antworten
mehr autonomie in strategischen
bereichen und das heißt bei
medizinischen produkten bei kritischen
rohstoffen und vor allem bei unserer
energieversorgung
und das heißt und das heißt raus aus
russischem öl und gas mehr investitionen
in klimaschutz mehr energieeffizienz
massiver ausbau der erneuerbaren die
bürgerinnen und bürger wollen ein
sozialeres europa und das heißt armut
und sozialer ausgrenzung bekämpfen das
heißt lohngleichheit in europa
herbeiführen und das heißt einen
gemeinsamen rahmen für mindesteinkommen
schaffen
und die bürgerinnen und bürger wollen
eine noch stärkere gemeinsame außen- und
verteidigungspolitik der europäischen
union und das heißt die abschaffung
nationaler retro gemeinsame streitkräfte
zur selbstverteidigung stärkung der
zivilen fähigkeiten und eine bessere
krisenprävention in europa
und all diese ziele das sind nur wenige
der über 300 maßnahmen die von den
bürgerinnen und bürger für eine
handlungsfähige eu erarbeitet wurden
wurden und wie wichtig zum beispiel die
abschaffung nationaler vetos in der eu
außenpolitik ist das können wir aktuell
gut beobachten eigentlich sind sich alle
einig dass wir raus aus russischen
ölriesen nur einer diesmal in budapest
sieht das anders und blockiert die
gesamte überfällige entscheidung und
verstehen sie mich bitte nicht falsch an
der stelle natürlich muss bei komplexen
fragen in der europäischen union über
unterschiedliche wege gestritten werden
und natürlich gibt es nicht immer eine
lösung für alle aber das ziel muss doch
das gleiche sein
denn wir dürfen uns nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen in der
außen und sicherheitspolitik wenn wir
eine relevante stimme in der welt sein
wollen dann kann diese stimme doch nur
im europäischen konzert erklingen
und deshalb deshalb müssen plumpe
erpressungen die wichtige entscheidungen
dauerhaft blockieren endlich der
vergangenheit angehören wir setzen uns
dafür ein dass die vorschläge der
zukunftskonferenz ernsthaft geprüft
werden und wo immer möglich in konkrete
entscheidungen münden
und das heißt auch möglicherweise ein
konvent und konkrete vertragsänderung
denn eine eu auf der höhe unserer zeit
das sind wir allen bürgerinnen und
bürgern schuldig aber auch den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die für diese
europäischen werte gerade kämpfen
und ich bin bundeskanzler scholz dankbar
dass er vor wenigen tagen noch einmal
klargestellt hat dass die ukraine
selbstverständlich zur europäischen
familie gehört und wie intensiv
begleiten
und ich bin aus ministerin werbung
dankbar dass sie in kiew betont hat dass
dieser weg in eine vollmitgliedschaft
führen wird und auch ich betone
vollmitgliedschaft und die ukraine weiß
dass es auf diesem weg keine rabatte
gibt und das will sie auch gar nicht das
sagen wir alle meine ukrainischen
gesprächspartnerin und gesprächspartner
sie wollen die gleichen
beitrittskriterien wie andere auch aber
gerade deshalb ist es so wichtig dass
die eu beitrittsperspektive glaubwürdig
ist und um das zu unterstreichen sollten
wir zum einen sehr schnell den
kandidatenstatus verleihen und zum
anderen die ukraine bestmöglich auch
finanziell beim wiederaufbau
unterstützen
robert schumann hatte am 9 1950 seine
europa erklärung mit folgendem satz
begonnen der friede der welt kann nicht
gewahrt werden ohne schöpferische
anstrengung die der größe der
bedrohungen entsprechen und dieser so
wahre realistische satz wurde schon auf
zitiert von mir haben von mir hier auch
aber selten waren wir in einer zeit in
der dieser satz so war als auftrag für
uns gelten musste und genau diesem
auftrag müssen wir uns widmen uns den
bedrohungen der welt zu stellen und
deshalb sind wir bereit all die
schöpferischen anstrengung aufzubringen
um den frieden in europa
wiederherzustellen vielen dank
robin wagner war das für die
bündnisgrünen und ebenfalls
europapolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion ist der nächste redner harald
weil für die afg spricht er
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin damen und herren im
raume und liebes wahl volk live und an
den endgeräten
nur ein paar grundgedanken und
alternativen zu den eben gehörten
regierungs absichten wieder die eigenen
bevölkerungs interessen und ökonomischen
erfordernisse
erstens war es schon ein kleines
versäumnis jetzt nicht des europäischen
rates in
brüssel sondern des europarates in
straßburg als forum für menschenrechte
und demokratie
russland und die ukraine hätten nämlich
vor dem 24 februar gemeinsam hinein
komplementiert werden müssen in die
umsetzung des 20 14 15 verhandelten
münster abkommens das könnte man
vielleicht sogar noch nachholen und
überhaupt so einiges umkehren was da
falsch gelaufen ist vielleicht klappt
das ja irgendwann mal in brüssel wenn
ich den straßen ruhig der genaue
unterschied zwischen russischer und
ukrainischer oligarchen wirtschaft
offener und verdeckter staatlicher
übergriffig kyte ist ohnehin gar nicht
mal so klar und auch in den usa und in
der eu gibt es ja oligarchen wie auch
immer man sie nennen markt dar zweitens
in der jetzigen situation ist da nicht
der hopplahopp nato-beitritt finnland
schweden von anderen will ich da gar
nicht erst reden er genau das falsche
stadt das richtige ich meine ein
marshall mannheim hätte da anders agiert
und diese hatte finnland und schweden
vielleicht gleich mit ja wohl nicht nur
vor einem gewissen österreicher gerettet
sondern sogar auch von einem gewissen
georg ja
mit wem gedenkt man eigentlich in moskau
irgendwann und wir reden zu können
was will man einem russland unter
welchem präsidenten auch immer jemals
anbieten kann nur ein us präsident mit
einem russischen verhandeln
und wie kläglich ist einmal mehr die
rolle der europäer die us nato muss
nicht nur der ukraine etwas abverlangen
sondern auch russland etwas anbieten wer
auch immer da regiert
drittens die amerikanische und viele
europäische regierungen sind derweil im
begriff ein weltwirtschaftskrise zu
entfachen der so noch nicht mal im
kalten krieg im kältesten krieg
stattgefunden hat immerhin hat dieser
das potenzial ungeachtet aller
militärischen vermisse eine neue
bipolarität einzuläuten in der ein
geschwächtes russland mit einem
gestärkten china amalgamiert oder eine
neue blockfreien bewegung hervor bringt
auch indien brasilien südafrika
indonesien
bringen hierbei ein außereuropäisches
gewicht halten dabei ist dann mehr den
je nach 19 45 oder auch nur 1990 sehr
die frage ob westdeutschland sich als
fünftes rad am wagen von anderer leute
interessen oder aber ebenfalls blog frei
ausrichten sollte als gedankenloser
finanzier und diener der schlechten
ideen und bequemlichkeiten anderer leute
hat das doppelte nachkriegsdeutschland
eine sehr trübe zukunftsaussicht und in
der gegenwart hätte man seit den 60er
jahren schon lernen können dass es nicht
gut ist ständig dem drängen anderer
staaten oder institutionen nachzugeben
man kann eine nadel so betreiben wie
frankreich das nach fast 50 jahren nach
dem urlaub erst 2009 in die militärische
integration zurückkehrte und man kann
die juso betreiben die italien seit 1957
und griechenland seit 1981 und
schließlich kann man selbst genauso
eigenständig und eigensinnig handeln wie
das liebe liebe washington mit dem man
natürlich weiter gegen das böse böse
moskau zu felde ziehen können und wenn
alles nichts hilft kein militär kein
boykott dann erinnere ich an die sato
die asiatischen naht also die 20 jahre
existierte usa frankreich großbritannien
australien neuseeland pakistan
philippinen thailand und die sich
1977 sogar selbst auflöste nachdem alle
welt gesehen hat dass selbst die
amerikanische katze im schutzbefohlenen
süd vietnam laos kambodscha keine mäuse
mehr fällt
einer der ganz wenigen anachronismen der
geschichte der sich je freiwillig selbst
aufgelöst hatte lange vor dem warschauer
pakt sogar und das beispiel sollte
vielleicht für die eine oder andere
institution die ebenfalls kleine mäuse
schenkt und mehr schaden verursacht als
nutzen stiftet auch gelten auf nun zur
vernunft und zum neuen weltfrieden danke
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
alexander graf lambsdorff
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
war jahre lang stellvertreter
sowjetunion ist es ziel deutscher
außenpolitik
ein
freies friedliches russland in einem
freien friedlichen europa aus
historischen gründen aus menschlichen
gründen aus kulturellen gründen aus
wirtschaftlichen aus politischen gründen
sind angebote gemacht worden ohne ende
transformationspartnerschaft eine
strategische partnerschaft
modernisierungspartnerschaft die vier
räume der nato russland rat ist es
wirklich viel angeboten worden nur eines
hat russland nicht verstanden jedenfalls
dass russland von heute
europa das ist nicht nur geografie
europa ist ein raum von frieden und
freiheit von recht und sicherheit und
zwar für alle nationen auf unserem
kontinent meine damen und herren nicht
nur für deutschland und frankreich
sondern eben auch für nationen wie
georgien und besonders die ukraine und
deshalb deshalb ist dieser angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine ein direkter angriff auf
europa auf unsere friedensordnung auf
das völkerrecht und damit sogar auf die
weltordnung die charta der vereinten
nationen manche sagen alle wären davon
überrascht gewesen ich glaube das ist
nicht ganz richtig wenn man präsident
putin gelesen hat wenn man ihm zugehört
hat dann konnte man heraushören dass
sich da etwas anbahnt etwas
zusammenbraut er hat diesen satz gesagt
dass der zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
die größte geopolitische katastrophe des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts gewesen sei oft
wird das in deutschland zitiert unter
weglassung des wortes geopolitisch aber
das ist wichtig weil putin gerade gesagt
hat geopolitik nicht gesagt die größte
ideologische katastrophe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts es geht ihm nicht um die
wiedererrichtung der sowjetunion und
deswegen missbraucht er jetzt die
geschichte als ideologie ersatz oben die
größe des russischen reiches durch
unterwerfung anderer nationen wieder
herzustellen meine damen und herren das
will putin erreichen aber was hat er
denn erreicht was hat putin wirklich
erreicht militärisch erst einmal
erheblich weniger als er sich erhofft
hat die schlacht in kiew ist dramatisch
verloren gegangen für die russische
seite er hat versucht den westen zu
spalten stattdessen hat er die einigkeit
des westens gefördert alle seine
versuche die nato zu spalten wie wir sie
aus den vertragsentwürfen die russin hat
im dezember vorgelegt hat die erde
heraus lesen konnten sind gescheitert
usa kanada europa unsere demokratischen
verbündeten im rest der welt wir sind
zusammengerückt was er zudem erreicht
hat ist nicht nur den zusammenhalt des
westens zu stärken hat konkret die
stärkung der nato erreicht dass schweden
nach 200 jahren seine neutralität
aufgibt und einem militärbündnis
beitritt ist eine historische zäsur im
ostseeraum und das filmen hat das gleich
mit macht ist für mich der viel mit
schwedischen und finnischen kolleginnen
und kollegen zusammenarbeiten durfte
eine der größten überraschungen der
dramatischen entwicklungen überhaupt ich
freue mich auf die schweden und die
finden der nato meine damen und herren
ich bin sicher das geht uns allen so
und wir haben auch innerhalb der nato
dinge getan deutschland hat die
ostflanke mit verstärkt in der slowakei
in rumänien durch ganz besonders auch in
litauen hier üben solidarität mit der
ukraine große unterstützung des werden
sanktionen gegen russland verhängt
werden waffen geliefert und ich verstehe
manche der bundeskanzler hat gesagt sie
machen sich sorgen was das für
auswirkungen auf unser
unsere wirtschaft unseren wohlstand
unser wachstum haben könnte aber ich
muss hier eines deutlich sagen die
ukraine nicht zu unterstützen das wäre
erheblich teurer als jetzt solidarität
mit der ukraine zu üben denn ein erfolg
russlands bei seinem unterwerfung
versucht wurde putin nur ermutigen
weiterzumachen auf seinem weg des
krieges deswegen ist die unterstützung
für die ukraine jetzt auch der
günstigere der bessere der klügere und
auch der moralisch richtige weg putin
hat zudem erreicht dass deutschland eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie
entwickelt in der die außenministerin
die wehr fähigkeit in den mittelpunkt
gerückt hat um unsere freiheit zu
schützen wir bekennen uns zum zwei
prozent ziel der nato endlich klar und
wir werden die bundeswehr durch ein
sondervermögen sterben ich freue mich
dass auch die union im prinzip dafür ist
die soldatinnen und soldaten warten
darauf es wäre schön wenn cdu und csu
hier von der bremse gehen würden und der
bundeswehr die stärkung zukommen lassen
auf die unsere männer und frauen in den
streitkräften zu dringen warten meine
damen und herren ein letzter punkt
auch die europäische union wir haben die
vorschläge von präsident ma con gehört
wir haben die zukunftskonferenz gehört
auch die europäische union wird sich
reformieren müssen wird sich stärken
müssen um unsere freiheit unsere werte
unsere demokratie zu verteidigen und
damit wir genau diese werte an kommende
generationen weitergeben können ich
danke ihnen herzlich
alexander graf lambsdorff von der fdp
hat gesagt europa ist ein raum von
frieden und freiheit von standsicherheit
der angriffskrieg auf die ukraine ist
ein direkter angriff auf europa und die
charta der vereinten nationen nina
scheer jetzt für die spd
eine der dringlichsten aufgaben dieser
zeit und damit auch für die anstehende
soll sich anschließenden zusammenkunft
des europäischen rats die
außerordentlich angesetzt ist ist
energiesicherheit auf die ich mich hier
nun konzentrieren möchte es ist falsch
wenn ihr vom rechten rand behauptet wird
dass mit energiewende fragen die kassen
und die geldbeutel der menschen
geplündert wurden das ist infam und dumm
so etwas zu unterstellen weil fakt ist
fakt ist dass wir in den alleine im märz
durch energiepreissteigerungen im
fossilen sektor 4,4 milliarden euro mehr
ausgegeben haben und insgesamt in der
europäischen union seit kriegsbeginn
50 milliarden euro an russland für
fossile energieimporte überlesen haben
50 milliarden euro das sind die zahlen
mit denen wir auf uns
auseinanderzusetzen habe und da gibt es
nur eine antwort dass wir so schnell wie
möglich die abhängigkeit von fossilen
ressourcen insbesondere natürlich die
importabhängigkeit von russland
reduzieren und auf null bringen müssen
das ist die einzige antwort
und wir haben damit jetzt auch gestern
noch mal weitere vorschläge von der
europäischen kommission
unterlegt bekommen die nun auch
gegenstand sein werden und die
fokussieren richtigerweise ein massives
aufwuchs programm für den umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien
195 milliarden euro sind dann nochmal
unterlegt alleine 95 prozent davon
sollen auf die erneuerbaren ziel und auf
einsparungsmaßnahmen das ist genau der
weg den wir brauchen und deswegen ist es
auch wichtig dass dies pünktlich zum
europäischen rat vorgelegt wird aber in
deutschland waren wir nicht untätig wir
haben schon enorme schritte in den
letzten wochen geschafft bei der
reduzierung der import abhängigkeiten im
fossilen sektor wir waren mit ihm im
gasbereich anfang des jahres noch bei
ungefähr 55 prozent abhängigkeit jetzt
sind wir bei 35% abhängigkeit wir waren
bei steinkohle anfang des jahres bei 50
prozent bei 8 prozent wir waren beim öl
bei 35 prozent nun sind wir bei zwölf
prozent das sind enorme leistungen für
deutschland gesprochen nicht noch nicht
für die gesamte europäische union
gesprochen aber es zeigt ein
industrieland wenn ein priester mit
deutschland dazu schafft dann sind wir
auf dem guten weg dies weiter
fortzusetzen in der gemeinsamkeit in der
europäischen union
ich möchte aber eingeben auf die frage
woher die preiskrise
auch vor dem krieg haben wir hatten eine
fossile energie preiskrise die bereits
vorher angesetzt hat und
die auseinandersetzung die wir auch hier
im deutschen bundestag schon geführt
haben etwa mit den entlastungs paket ii
war eben kennzeichen dieser fossilen
energie preiskrise auch schon vor dem
krieg das müssen wir ganz klar
fokussieren denn das bedeutet dass
unsere anstrengungen noch immer diesen
dramatischen konflikt hinaus gehen
müssen und ich möchte betonen dass das
eine soziale frage ist die abhängigkeit
von fossilen energien zu beenden ist
eine soziale frage weil wir sonst
energie armut bekommen wir bekommen
keine
teilhabe keine entwicklungsperspektive
auch für ärmere länder auf der welt wenn
wir nicht die unabhängigkeit von
endlichen fossilen ressourcen gewinde
kommen das ist der kosmos im zentrum
stehen genauso wichtig ist die
begrenzung des klimawandels aber es muss
uns deutlich werden dass auch ohne den
klimawandel wir genau das gleiche tun
müsse wir müssen so schnell wie möglich
die importabhängigkeit und generelle
abhängigkeit von fossilen ressourcen
beenden
und insofern ist es richtig dass die
europäische union nun vorgelegt hat ein
massives aufwuchs programm zur sohle 1
es soll verdoppelt werden was an
solarenergieausbau passiert wir müssen
einen grenz ausgleichsmechanismus
hinbekommen das ist schon eine längere
zeit in der diskussion damit es sich
lohnt auf co2 arme technologien zu
setzen und energieeinsparung vorziehen
und damit das nicht im wettbewerb
weggedrückt wird dafür muss es einen
ausgleichsmechanismus geben anders ist
das im weltweiten wettbewerb nicht zu
buchen dieses ibm system muss kommen und
es muss auch passieren und da muss auch
noch in den nächsten wochen darauf
hingewirkt werden wir haben massive
ungleichgewichte
wenn es um begünstigung bzw ausnahme
vorschriften von leitlinien geht beim im
kontext der korona pandemie ist es uns
gelungen richtigerweise um einfach die
wirtschafts fähigkeit die die hilfs
fähigkeit gewährleisten zu können auch
ausnahmen von beide vorschriften in der
europäischen union festzunehmen
festzuschreiben das muss jetzt auch bei
den erneuerbaren energien gelten wir
dürfen uns hier nicht selbst im wege
stehen die europäische kommission hat
gestern ein richtiger weise gesagt 60
darf eine genehmigung nur dauern nicht
mehrere jahre und genau das hatte auch
olaf scholz immer auch immer und immer
wieder betont dass muss im zentrum
stehen der beschleunigte ausbau
erneuerbarer energien und da dürfen wir
diese genehmigungs handys in nicht
länger forderungen
energiesicherheit ist insofern eine
europäische wertschöpfungs frage mit
solarzellen mit windkraftanlagen aber
auch speichern und natürlich auch
wasserstoff technologie
wir müssen dabei auch die monopol
abhängigkeiten überwinden und herr merz
noch mal ihre adressen wenn sie meinen
dass über die letzten 10 jahren alles
richtig gelaufen sein der handelspolitik
da muss ich ihnen widersprechen
die abwanderung der deutschen
solarindustrie ist eine neoliberale an
der liberale effekt wir haben nicht
dafür sorge getragen dass die
ökologie soziale ökologische wende die
wir brauchen das die sich auch in der
handelspolitik niedergeschlagen hat und
wenn sie das immer noch nicht erkannt
haben dann wird es auch in die aus ihren
herein daraus sicher keine guten
vorschläge geben um diesen wandel hin zu
bekommen um auch konstruktive vorschläge
auf diesem weg dahin zu bekommen wir
müssen die wirtschaft in der
europäischen union halten das macht uns
unabhängig das bringt energiesicherheit
viel tanz
nina scheer war das sehr schön
eingefangen im bild der kanzler im
gespräch mit lars klingbeil dem
spd-fraktionsvorsitzenden worum es dabei
wohl geht gunther krichbaum jetzt für
die cdu/csu
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen kollegen
zunächst begrüßen wir es dass es heute
morgen eine regierungserklärung gibt
denn es gehört hier nicht nur zu einer
festen tradition sondern zu den rechten
des parlaments dass sich die regierung
vor einem europäischen rat erklärt das
war so in den letzten monaten etwas in
vergessenheit geraten aber wir werden
hier der regierung auch in zukunft auf
die finger schauen dass das stattfindet
nun
bundeskanzler scholz er hat viel geredet
aber nichts gesagt wir hätten uns
nämlich gewünscht dass sich die
regierung erklärt es wäre eine chance
gewesen insbesondere im hinblick auf die
ukraine und das kannst du stolz spricht
selbst von der zeitenwende mir ist
mittlerweile klar warum er diesen
begriff gewählt hat weil er für diese
wende zeit braucht das ist aber zeit die
die ukraine nicht hat man rühmt sich
dass man mittlerweile sieben
panzerhaubitzen geliefert hat man muss
sich aber vor augen halten dass die
fläche der ukraine ungefähr doppelt so
groß ist wie die der bundesrepublik
deutschland herunter gebrochen hieße
dass im zahlen ungefähr eine halbe hand
panzerhaubitze für ganz nordrhein
westfalen
das ist viel zu wenig deswegen
bundeskanzler scholz bitte gehen sie her
liefern sie waffen liefern sie das was
die ukraine braucht wenn sie heute hier
erklären einem land bei der verteidigung
zu helfen ist keine eskalation dann kann
man auch das tun was die ukraine jetzt
braucht nicht warme worte sondern taten
das alleine zählt in diesem bitteren
zeigen
wir müssen darauf schauen dass die
ukraine den krieg militärisch nicht
verliert aber vor allem auch nicht
ökonomisch kollabiert deswegen ist es
richtig dass die länder der europäischen
union hier finanziell zu dazu beitragen
aber bitte nicht mit dem instrument das
gewählt wurde beim netz generation eu
gemeinsame schulden helfen in diesem
fall nicht weiter sondern eine finanz
partnerschaft gemeinsam vor allem auch
mit dem iwf dieses schlagwort ist heute
noch nicht gefallen denn hier brauchen
wir auch internationale unterstützung um
damit das feld auch komplett wird nach
meinem verständnis muss immer noch der
verein schaden geradestehen der ihn
verursacht hat und das ist russland wir
sollten deswegen auch völkerrechtlich
alle möglichkeiten und wege prüfen damit
russland herangezogen werden wird im
falle ihm im bereich der reparationen
das ist nicht einfach das ist schwierig
aber was ist die in diesen taten auch
schon einfach aber russland muss her
herangezogen werden und auch die
russischen
devisenreserven nun hätte ich mir auch
ein klares wort gewünscht im hinblick
auf den europäischen rat aber auch
durchaus noch im rahmen der
französischen ratspräsidentschaft zu dem
perspektiv der ukraine und es kann es
war scholz sagt ja die ukraine hat eine
europäische perspektive ja was heißt das
ich bin der überzeugung dass der ukraine
der kandidaten status eingeräumt werden
muss und das auch noch während der
französischen ratspräsidentschaft
damit hier keine missverständnisse
eintreten ein beitrittsverfahren erst
recht für diese länder die jetzt
anstehen ist ein jahrzehnte langer
prozess da hat präsident marco
ausdrücklich recht es gibt kein
schnellverfahren es gibt kein fast track
verfahren in die europäische union
hinein das lässt schon artikel 49 der
verträge gar nicht zu es wäre auch nicht
vermittelbar gegenüber den staaten des
sogenannten westlichen balkans es wäre
zudem auch eine überforderung der
europäischen union selbst aber vor allem
und ganz entscheidendes wird nicht
einmal vor der ukraine selbst
eingefordert nun müssen wir doch in
einem punkt schauer wenn man jedenfalls
mich gefragt hätte etwas mehr als 30
jahren wie die europäische union heute
aussieht ich hätte dir erkennbar falsche
antwort gegeben deswegen sollten wir uns
der perspektive doch auch bei den ich
verschließen wie die europäische union
im 30 und 40 jahren aussieht und da ist
es eben wichtig ein starkes signal zu
liefern auch ein geostrategisches etwas
wo die europäische union sicherlich noch
hineinwachsen muss und wir brauchen ein
modell für die staaten die heute der
europäischen union nicht beitreten
wollen die die nicht beitreten können
die die nicht beitreten noch nicht
beitreten können lassen sie uns gerne
als eine assoziierte mitgliedschaft
bezeichnen aber es muss glaubwürdig sein
als eine zwischenstation nicht
endstation damit würde sich dieses
modell deutlich von der privilegierten
partnerschaft
unterscheiden was hier nicht
vermittelbaren waren ein letzter satz
wir brauchen signale der unterstützung
für die ukraine lassen sie uns unsere
städte und kommunen ermutigen
städtepartnerschaften einzugehen das
wird viel schneller gehen als ein
beitrittsverfahren in die europäische
union das ist konkrete hilfe oder wie es
vielleicht auch albanien gemacht hat in
diesen tagen hat die stadtverwaltung von
tirana die straße in der die russische
botschaft ihren sitz im benannten straße
der ukrainischen unabhängigkeit und
freiheit herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die spd-fraktion
fabian funke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren seit dem 24 februar ist
die welt nicht mehr die gleiche wie
zuvor die russische föderation hat mit
ihrem furchtbaren angriffskrieg
gegenüber der ukraine auch unsere welt
in deutschland und europa verändert und
sicher geglaubte grundsätze infrage
gestellt ich als jemand der in einem
geeinten deutschland und europa
aufgewachsen ist der den eisernen
vorhang nur noch aus erzählungen kennt
und der beim kosovo krieg gerade so
geboren war hätte mir nicht vorstellen
können dass wir in europa noch einmal
einen so fürchterlichen krieg erleben
unsere solidarität gilt den ukrainischen
bürgerinnen und bürgern die unter diesem
krieg leiden und auch jetzt gerade
während wir hier sitzen die last des
krieges ertragen müssen
die ukraine hat nicht nur jedes recht
sich gegen diesen angriff zu verteidigen
sehr gar keine andere option als sich
aktiv zu verteidigen und verdient unsere
volle unterstützung denn das was unter
russischer besatzung geschieht haben wir
mit den furchtbaren bildern aus butter
gesehen deswegen ist es auch genau
richtig dass die bundesregierung und
bundeskanzler olaf scholz die ukraine
entlang unserer möglichkeit mit allen
mitteln unterstützt sei es mit der
lieferung von waffen oder humanitären
gütern
dabei werden die gesprächskanäle für
diplomatische lösungen
selbstverständlich nicht geschlossen
aber wir müssen uns doch auch keine
illusionen machen von alleine ohne druck
wird putin nicht an den
verhandlungstisch kommen und auch nicht
die integrität der ukraine respektieren
auch wenn das in teilen dieses plenum
scheinbar immer noch nicht angekommen
ist und weiterhin zugeständnisse von der
ukraine gefordert werden
neben einen nationalen anstrengungen die
wir leisten und leisten müssen braucht
es auch die für die stärkung unserer
demokratien in europa entschlossenheit
und geschlossenheit und die haben wir
die letzten wochen hier auch gelebt das
motto der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft lautet europäische
souveränität und wir brauchen ein
souveränes europa mehr als je zuvor und
ein souveränes europa wie wir es uns
vorstellen ist nicht abhängig von
fossilen energieträgern autokratischen
staaten ein souveränes europa ist in
krisenzeiten geschlossen und
handlungsfähig
ein souveränes europa steht mit beiden
beinen fest auf den grundsätzen der
demokratie
diplomatie und wirtschaftlichen
zusammenarbeit aber lässt keinen zweifel
daran dass es wert ist wenn diktaturen
und autokratien des recht des stärkeren
einfordern wollen
und auch in europa hat sich die letzten
wochen und monate einiges verändert
europa ist geschlossen seiner reaktion
auf russland die geschwindigkeit und
schlagkraft der bisherigen sanktions
pakete sind ein klarer beweis dafür aber
auch die union zahlt für diese
sanktionen ihren preis und für einige
länder ist der preis für diese sanktion
höher als für andere insbesondere unsere
zentral und osteuropäischen partnerinnen
beispielsweise tschechien fällt es
deutlich schwerer sich unabhängiger von
russischer energie und anderen
lieferungen zu machen und wir sollten
das anerkennen und darin keinen grund
sehen über uneinigkeit zu geben sondern
eher den willen sich zu einigen ist das
erkennen was es ist europäische stärke
und geschlossenheit
und wenn es gibt es im rechtsstaat
bereich weiterhin auch in osteuropa
viele sachen anzumerken und das tun wir
aber das soll nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass europa gerade
geschlossen eine große leistung
vollbringt denn bei einer zweifelsfreien
wichtigkeit unserer historischen
freundschaft zu frankreich der
bundeskanzler hat es heute auch noch mal
erwähnt und der unserem engen
schulterschluss zu paris besteht
europaweit mehr aus den stars aus den
staaten westlich der oder und des
erzgebirges für mich ganz persönlich
aufgewachsen an der tschechischen grenze
bestand europa in meiner kindheit
nämlich vor allem aus den offenen
grenzen und dem austausch mit unserem
östlichen nachbarland tschechien und
auch eine aus einer schule in meinem
herkunftsort in dem seit 25 jahren
deutsche und tschechische schüler innen
gemeinsam lernen und für und als
generation ist demzufolge europa auch
mehr als nur eine bloße wirtschafts und
verteidigungs union denn diesen eindruck
konnte man vor uns bei herrn dobrindt
gewinnen
und deswegen ist mir auch besonders
wichtig dass wir in zukunft die
perspektiven mittel und osteuropas noch
viel ernster nehmen als dies der
vergangenheit der fall war deshalb ist
es auch richtig dass die bundesregierung
mit dem ringtausch unserer partner in
der zentral- und osteuropa sie dazu
befähigt schwere waffen an die ukraine
zu liefern und gleichzeitig ihre
wehrhaftigkeit unterstützt deshalb ist
es richtig dass die bundeswehr ihre
verantwortung in der nato gerecht wird
und weiter im baltikum in rumänien in
der slowakei und in bulgarien
unterstützt deswegen ist es auch
besonders wichtig dass der bundeskanzler
schon früh erklärt hat dass er die
mitgliedschaft von schweden und finnland
in der leitung unterstützt
und deshalb ist es richtig dass der
bundeskanzler sich auch im europäischen
rat dafür einsetzt dass alle staaten der
europäischen union die hilfe bekommen
die sie benötigen um so schnell wie
möglich unabhängig von fossilen
energieträgern russland zu werden und
ihre industrie klimaneutral umzubauen
aber auch darüber hinaus muss sich die
union weiter entwickeln in zeiten in
denen staaten aktiv die bindung zu den
werten und versprechen der europäischen
institutionen suchen ist es wichtig auch
endlich die beitritts besucher der
staaten auf dem westbalkan ernst zu
nehmen und eine ehrliche perspektive zu
geben und auch hier danke ich den
bundeskanzler für seine klare initiative
und haltung die ja auch gerade noch
einmal deutlich gemacht
ich bin der festen überzeugung die union
steht vor großen herausforderungen und
gleichzeitig vor einer historischen
chance gemeinsame sicherheit energie
unabhängigkeit und die lösung der
klimakrise die auch meine generation
besonders betrifft liegen vor uns diese
herausforderungen können wir nur
gemeinsam lösen in diesem sinne hoffen
wir auf einen erfolgreichen europäischen
rat und ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege stefan seidler
vielen dank frau präsidentin neuen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
öl-embargo gegen russland ist ebenso
richtig wie die reform der
bundesregierung zur beschleunigung des
ausbaus der erneuerbaren energien es ist
wichtig dass wir europäer g1 stehen und
die abhängigkeit reduzieren dass dies in
brüssel gelingt dafür hat der
bundeskanzler hier im hause breite
unterstützung die konsequenz aus dem
embargo darf aber nicht sein dass wir
nun die öl und gasförderung in der
nordsee
ausweiten
hier wird der mit stimmen auch aus der
bundesregierung der nationalpark und das
unesco welterbe wattenmeer ist als
einzigartiges ökosystem dadurch bedroht
es stellt sich die frage wie können wir
bis 2045 klimaneutral sein wenn etwa
wintershall die die ölförderung auf der
mittelplate bis 20 69 verlängern will
über die abholzung des amazonas empören
wir uns zu recht doch sind wir so viel
besser wenn wir unser eigenes wattenmeer
nun durchbohren beschädigen wollen
zum gas in europa gibt es 37 lng
terminal deren kapazitäten sollten wir
erstmal auslasten bevor wir neue anlagen
für schmutziges allen teuer einrichten
zumal der gasbedarf in zukunft eher
sinken wird
herr bundeskanzler gemeinsam mit
bundesminister robert habeck waren sie
gestern im dänischen sbm den ausbau der
windkraft in der nordsee mit den
anrainerstaaten zu besprechen
europäische kooperation ist genau der
weg den wir brauchen sprechen sie
deshalb auf dem gipfel in brüssel
bitte nicht nur über fossile
energieträger sondern auch wie wir
gemeinsam in europa die erneuerbaren
stärken vielen dank stefan seiler war
das vom südschleswigschen wählerverband
und er hat noch mal dran erinnert ja
gestern war eine sozusagen kleiner
nordsee gipfel mit deutschland
niederlande auf einladung von in
dänemark und belgien war noch dabei um
gemeinsam den windkraftausbau
voranzubringen
und jetzt haben wir noch einen letzten
redner jetzt aussprache zur
regierungserklärung jörg nürnberger ist
das für die spd ende mai in brüssel
behandelt werden steht alle im
zusammenhang mit dem verbrecherischen
krieg in russland gegen die ukraine
führt es wird daher bei diesem rat gangs
vor gericht um die fragen der
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik gehen wir vertreten
als spd fraktion einen umfassenden
sicherheitsbegriff der ganz verschiedene
aspekte von sicherheit beinhaltet ich
möchte ich mich hier in meiner rede weil
ich mitglied in europa und im
verteidigungsausschuss bin auch den
bereich klassische sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik konzentrieren
bundeskanzler oder stolz hat die
entsprechenden und entscheidenden
maximen des regierungshandelns in dieser
zeit des krieges in europa bereits
beschrieben das wichtigste prinzip ist
wir stehen an der seite der ukraine
unterstütze sind nach allen unseren
kräften
gleichzeitig gilt dabei deutschland und
die nato dürfe nicht zur kriegspartei
werden wir stimmen unser handeln stets
mit unseren partnern ab die deutsche
indie bündnis verteidigungsfähigkeit
darf nicht eingeschränkt werden und das
letzte ziel und das wichtigste ziel
russland auf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
die gegenseitige abstimmung mit unseren
partnern in europa und der westlichen
welt ist dabei besonders wichtig bereits
seit der deutschen ratspräsidentschaft
im jahr 2020 haben die
eu-mitgliedstaaten ihre zusammenarbeit
im bereich der sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik verstärkt mit dem
beschluss des strategischen kompasses im
märz haben wir nun eine neue grundlage
für sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitische zusammenarbeit
auf der ebene der eu geschaffen mit dem
kompass ist eine grundlage für schnelle
reaktionsmöglichkeiten der eu in
krisenzeiten geschaffen worden um somit
unsere europäischen bürgerinnen und
bürger noch besser schützen zu können
die aufstellung einer entsprechenden
europäischen eingreiftruppe gehört dazu
wir werden diesen kompass für die für
sicherheit auch künftig stets
nachjustieren wenn es notwendig sein
wird
gleichzeitig und das kann nicht oft
genug gesagt werden geht es in der eu
nicht um den aufbau von doppelstrukturen
sondern immer nur um eine ergänzung der
zusammenarbeit mit unseren nato partnern
die beabsichtigte aufnahme der
eu-mitgliedstaaten finnland und schweden
in die nato mit hier nochmals eine
verbesserung der sicherheitslage für
alle europäerinnen und europäer mit sich
bringen der türkische präsident sollte
daher seine ablehnende position
überdenken da diese erweiterung zwar
nicht die südflanke betrifft aber eben
insgesamt die nadel stärkt wovon auch
die türkei profitieren wird
die bedeutung einer starken europäischen
verteidigung ist mir erst auch wieder an
diesem wochenende ganz konkreten bewusst
geworden am sonntag war ich als einziger
abgeordneter aus dem bundestag gast
nachdem die übungs platz bergen bei
einer gefechtsübung wo 7500 männer und
frauen aus neun nationen
ganz aktuell für den ernstfall üben der
hoffentlich nie eintreten wird das zeigt
unsere stärke unserer bündnisse wir sind
einlagen nationen zusammen zu führen und
ein team zu bilden eine gemeinsame
verteidigung uns verbinden die werte und
die absicht die freiheit unsere
liberalen demokratien gegen alle
autokraten dieser welt zu verteidigen
wir stehen zusammen
dieser eindruck hast du ja auch
verstärkt in litauen wo ich die
den deutschen anteil der und hans robert
bressons battlegroup litauen besucht
haben genau hier an der nato ostflanke
sind ist ängste und sorgen durch den
großen angriff auf die ukraine besonders
groß
meine schwiegereltern zum beispiel haben
den einmarsch der sowjetischen truppen
nach tschechien live miterlebt und
selbst meine frau der jahrgang 1971 ist
konnte immer noch geschehen beobachten
diese einmal hinterlassen hat und zwar
nicht nur an den gebäuden in liberec
sondern auch an den einstellungen der
bevölkerung und dem verhältnis gegenüber
der sowjetunion und jetzt ist und ein
letzte eindruck noch mal aus tschechien
das sich am dritten und vierten mal in
chats der ort wo er herkommt besucht
habe hier sind nämlich diejenigen
tschechischen truppen stationiert die
einerseits sehr eng mit der zehnten
panzerdivision in nordbayern
zusammenarbeiten und die sich aktuell
auch gerade auf ihren einsatz in der
slowakei vorbereiten dort werden erneut
deutsche und tschechische soldatinnen
zusammenarbeit und russland vor einer
aggression auch nato und eu gebiet
aufzuschrecken warum erzähle ich das
alles ich erzählte das deshalb weil eben
diese zusammenarbeit der entscheidende
faktor ist um die europäische sicherheit
voranzubringen
unsere partner wünschen sich nämlich ein
starkes europäisches engagement in
sicherheitspolitischen fragen die
bundesregierung olaf scholz setzen hier
genau die richtigen schwerpunkte
eine abgeordnete aus einem kleineren
nato staat hat es diese woche so
ausgedrückt früher haben wir uns vor
einem starken deutschland gefürchtet
heute wünschen wir uns ein stabiles und
ein starkes deutschland das seine
verantwortung in europa gerecht wird
auch das ist eine zeitenwende
denn gerade deutschland als garant für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
gesehen wird daher vertrauen auf unsere
partner in europa darauf dass wir
unseren beitrag zur militärischen
verteidigung leisten dazu gehört die
errichtung des 100 milliarden
sondervermögens der bundeswehr und ein
wort an die oppositionszeitung gestattet
wenn man sie im plenum beobachtet spürt
man wie zwei herzen in ihrer brust
schlagen auf der einen seite spürt man
das doch ein gewisses gefühl für
staatspolitische verantwortung haben
aber auf der anderen seite
offensichtlich auch andere motive sie
treiben bitte geben sie sich den druck
und werden sie ihrer verantwortung
gerecht olaf scholz und die
bundesregierung verfolgen nämlich genau
dieses ziel und zeigen durch ihre
entschlossene und gleichzeitig besondere
vorgehensweise in den vergangenen wochen
dass sie diese verantwortung gerecht
werden dafür gebührt der gesamten
regierung und insbesondere olaf scholz
unsere anerkennung und unsere
unterstützung vielen dank wie wirken
nürnberger war das für die spd fraktion
der letzte redner und olaf scholz hier
sehen sie ihn noch mal angefangen von
der bildregie vielen dank dafür sitzt in
den reihen der abgeordneten zusammen
übrigens etwas verdeckt hier mit britta
haßelmann der fraktionsvorsitzende der
bündnisgrünen hatte er die ganze zeit
dann doch schon einiges zu besprechen ja
olaf scholz hat in seiner
regierungserklärung deutlich gemacht uns
alle eint ein ziel so der bundeskanzler
russland darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen die ukraine muss bestehen und
olaf scholz
verteidigte auch noch mal die lieferung
schwerer waffen der kanzler reist erst
jahr 33 31 mai dann nach brüssel zu
diesem außerordentlichen eu gipfel heute
allerdings wird ja schon nach den haag
reisende in den niederlanden gibt es
verschiedene gespräche unter anderem
trifft er könig willem alexander und den
ministerpräsidenten mark rutte in dem
gespräch dürfte es vor allem um den
ukraine krieg und auch seine folgen
gehen so dann kommen wir zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt es geht um planungs
und genehmigungsverfahren die sollen
schneller werden für die cdu fraktion
spricht als erster steffen bilger
schneller werden die sich stellenden
herausforderungen sind enorm
der nachhaltige umbau hin zur
klimaneutralität die digitalisierung die
sorge um die leistungskraft unserer
volkswirtschaft und der erhalt der
versorgungssicherheit wir brauchen
umfassende investitionen und zwar nicht
irgendwann